(crew chatting)
- Yeah, I'm a little bit.
- [Man] Cool, live?
- Yeah.
I am live, but the phone numbers
are gonna come on Twitter.
Hit me up with your number on Twitter.
I want to see if this goes out.
I wanna do it just for the dare.
This is the phone number.
You're gonna start seeing
numbers coming on Twitter.
Like phone numbers, I
assume at some point.
What is up YouTube, Facebook?
What do we got?
Facebook?
YouTube?
- Facebook what?
- [Woman] First in line.
- First in line community on Facebook.
Love that.
Facebook over all.
- [Man] Yep.
- Facebook and YouTube there.
That's the vlog.
That means no Instagram?
(crew chatting)
- Awesome.
Cool.
(crew chatting)
Oh, we posted 24/7?
Good.
What's Caleb--
(crew chatting)
What's Caleb doing?
(laughing)
This is amazing.
I'm sharing that.
Where is Caleb?
Getting rained on?
- [Man] Yeah, I guess so.
- All right, we're live, right?
(laughing)
All right, everybody's watching.
Oh, this video's catching.
This is doing well.
- People like it, right?
It's funny.
Did we change it to Cynics?
Did we take that?
- Yes.
- We made that change?
That guy's name happen to be Gary?
- [Man] Yeah, straight up though.
- And it happen to go viral,
or we found something?
- [Man] It was--
- This thing was going viral over all?
- They did CBD and they--
(woman yelling)
- (laughs) This is fucking funny.
All right, about to call some peeps.
Is Instagram Live on?
- Yes.
- About to be.
- About to be, all right.
- [Man] Katie has it.
- All right, you get
phone numbers let's go.
Just take them.
Give them to me.
Ready?
I got you, 201.
Jersey, got it?
- Yep.
- 250.
- 6859.
Everybody's watching.
I'm just in the mood to answer questions.
I'm just gonna answer fucking questions.
That's what I'm about to
do, and people that are part
of my new text messaging platform
in the Beta are the
ones that are getting--
- [Jacobi] Hi, who is this?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
Who's this?
- [Jacobi] Holy shit!
No way!
This is Jacobi Douglas.
- What up, Cobi?
- [Jacobi] How you doing, man?
Huge fan.
- Too good.
Thank you, man, what's your question?
- [Jacobi] So, my question to you is like
how do you know when to trust your head
versus trusting your gut?
- Trust your gut.
- [Jacobi] Why do you say that?
- Well, you fucking
asked me a question, bro.
I gave you an answer, because I--
- [Jacobi] How do you know the difference?
Like what would you say is a better time
to trust one versus the other?
- Trust your gut every time.
- [Jacobi] Okay.
- Because I live life around regrets,
and I think more people
regret not trusting
their gut than trusting their head.
Plus you're young as fuck, and the younger
you are the more you
should trust your gut,
because your head's filled with nonsense
from parents and society, and school.
And it actually makes you
go on defense in your 20's
and 30's when you should
be on fucking on offense.
Is that a better answer?
- [Jacobi] Thank you.
I'm sorry I was not cool.
- No, no, I was joking.
I'm joking with you dude.
I'm joking.
You don't need to be sorry.
The reason I answered gut
is I really believe the answer is gut.
- [Jacobi] I feel that.
I'm in the military right now.
So I don't know.
It's one of those things
where it's like I don't know.
Cause you need to trust your
first instinct or whatever.
- Trust your first instinct.
- [Jacobi] So yeah, thanks man.
I'm a huge fan.
I listen to a lot of your podcasts,
and--
- I appreciate you.
- [Jacobi] And your videos...
On YouTube.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Jacobi] My dad introduced me to you,
so I was like super excited about it
when I was like I wasn't
expecting a call that fast.
- That's how we do it, Cobi.
I wish you well, man.
Thank you.
- [Jacobi] Oh, man.
- All right, good.
Let's keep it going, Andy.
- [Woman] I have a
person online that says,
"Hey Gary and crew.
"Love the ATVs this week."
- Loved them this week.
They were good, right?
The lady's was hilarious.
Are we clipping that fucking Jose call?
That Jose call's a 15 minute IGTV banger.
- [Man] It's already on it?
- The way that thing ends...
(line trilling)
That's what I want.
Like wait for it in the end.
That's the way you title that one.
Like that's what--
- [Mike] Hello?
- Mike, it's Gary Vaynerchuk .
- [Mike] Whoa!
- Yep.
- Hi.
- Hey, how are you?
(Mike laughing)
- [Mike] I always told
myself I wouldn't be
one of those people
that's like, holy shit,
is this actually happening?
- But you had like a second,
'cause I was calling,
and you probably assumed
that that was it, right?
Or did you think somebody was
pranking you or something?
- [Mike] Well, I get a lot of robot calls,
but this one said New
York, and I was like,
oh fuck, oh fuck it might be him.
(Gary laughing)
- That's what's up man.
What can I answer for you?
- [Mike] Well, okay, so
I'm a singer/song writer,
and I'm 39-years-old,
and I've been doing it for a long time.
- Yes.
- Since I was very young.
I've only in the last couple
of years really embraced
the online social media platforms,
and I've been on Facebook
forever, and that kind of stuff.
- Sure.
- [Mike] I was always like,
I'm just gonna make records.
It was so stupid like I get it now.
This is just the world we live in.
So, I've been consuming your
content for a couple of years,
and I'm in that like making,
making, making content,
documenting the process;
that kind of thing.
- Yes.
- [Mike] And the thing
is I have three projects.
I sing.
There's my solo project.
There's me with my best friend,
and we have a whole duo, and then
we also have a four-piece band.
- Okay.
- [Mike] And so I'm tried to figure out
if I should lean into
branding myself as the guy
who has these three projects,
or should I just focus on my.
'cause my solo project is
called "Dear, Mr. Henshaw."
It's kind of like my alter ego.
- Okay.
- [Mike] I play drums with my feet,
and stuff like that, so--
- Let me ask a question.
Straight up.
No bullshit.
Which one do you feel best about?
Like you like the most
and feel has the most
like net net best of these three things,
which one do you feel best about?
- [Mike] So, the interesting
thing is the four-piece band,
"Sons of Guns", that's
what I feel best about,
but there's three other guys
involved in three different places.
- That's the answer to your
question; just so you know.
- [Mike] Yeah, I have
less control over that,
and so with my solo project--
- So why do you feel best about that?
Because best doesn't mean what
you think is furthest along right now.
Best means net net, right?
- [Mike] Yeah, yeah.
- You can't be like if
the four-piece is best,
and then the next thing
coming out of your mouth
were four reason why not.
So, maybe you thought maybe
that's the furthest along
from a short term success stand point,
but maybe it's not the best.
- [Mike] Right, yeah, no.
I mean I definitely net.
It's gotta be a different
franchise with the solo project.
- That's what you need to get into.
The question for everybody
who's got things like that
is not what's furthest along.
People are like this
one thing's making 50K.
This one thing's 8K.
This one thing I'm losing money on,
but what do you feel best about?
AKA you like the most, and you think
you could be successful, because
you might like the 50K one the most,
but you might not think
it has the most upside,
or you like this.
What people don't understand
is we settle too often,
and what we need to
move in on is the thing
that checks as many of
the boxes as possible.
When you're faced with choices,
and you don't know, you go with the one
that if all works out...
Everybody goes with defense.
They have three things in front of them,
and they're like, "What can go wrong?"
I go the other way.
Of these three things,
if they all went perfect,
which would I be most happy about?
The middle one.
That one.
Do you understand?
- [Mike] Yep.
Now, if you have to
balance that with delusion.
You may like your solo
alter-ego project the most,
because you don't get
feedback from anybody else.
You might be delusional.
- [Mike] Yeah.
Yeah, no that's true.
You get more versatility out of music
with a four-piece band, and
a lot more collaboration.
The thing about the solo project--
- When you went into, "I
don't have as much control,"
and different things
that's a very logical,
and practical thing, so I think the thing
about doing something for a long time,
and now being 39 is it's incredible.
You're young as fuck
You also have sounds like 20 years of data
that says, okay, here's what it is.
You're 20 years in.
You've gotta decide
what are we doing here.
Like at 17 it's about I'm gonna
fucking make it, and fame.
At 39, do you still feel that?
Is this now about loving the game?
Loving the process?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- Is this about I couldn't?
One of the things that most
people don't understand about me
is I just couldn't do anything else.
If I was--
- [Mike] Right.
- If I was one-one
thousandth as successful...
Look at me.
With my hundredth of an inch of free time
I want a garage sale.
- [Mike] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't have any other fucking gear.
This isn't about options.
This is about happiness.
- [Mike] Yeah, and I'm the same way.
I'm still doing it,
because I can't not do it.
- Good, good for you.
- [Mike] And I can't
work for somebody else.
I mean I'll hustle.
I'll do what I gotta do.
- I got it.
I got.
- [Mike] Just to be clear.
When I say control with the band,
I don't mean it like creative control
I mean literally like if
somebody offers us a gig
we have to check with three other guys
to see how they're schedule are.
- Oh, I followed you.
I followed you.
I didn't think you wanted
to be the ring leader.
I thought that Barney
might have a flat tire.
- [Mike] Yeah, I just want
to make a video everyday,
and play a show every week,
and hit tour five times a year.
And I just want to play play play.
- So, why don't you lean into all of them?
- [Mike] Yeah, I've
been doing that lately,
but in terms of branding
do you think I should
just be like fucking flinging
three different Instagram
accounts just switching it back
and forth and doing it all?
- Yeah!
- [Mike] (laughs) all right.
- Or post them all on one.
- [Mike] Yeah.
- I've got an Instagram account where
you don't know if the
video's gonna be about me
flipping a $4 teddy bear,
or like having a fucking
conversation with the CO of Verizon.
- [Mike] Right, right.
Okay, yeah yeah totally.
- Just be you.
- Okay.
- Cool. See ya.
Getting back to be you.
Go ahead, Andy I'm ready.
By the way everybody who's watching
like the only advantage you have is you.
There's so much content at this point.
Like you playing some character,
or trying to compete at some
vanilla game is no shot.
Like the only thing you have
is your subtle ridiculousness.
(line trilling)
We're now in the game of edges.
It is the weirdness, Sarah.
(line trilling)
Like the fact that you love
peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches is like a variable now.
(line trilling)
- [Sarah] Hello.
Hey, Sarah it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
(laughing)
- [Sarah] Hi, how are you?
- I'm super well.
How are you?
- [Sarah] I'm doing fantastic.
Thank you.
- What can I answer for you?
- [Sarah] I started a business
about 4 1/2 years ago.
(muffled speaking)
I stopped following up with people.
I stopped taking care of my customers,
and I really wanna get back on it,
and I wanna--
- And why did that happen?
(Sarah sighs)
For real.
- [Sarah] Personal stuff.
- Personal stuff, okay.
- [Sarah] Yeah, a lot of personal stuff,
and I also I think I just got burned out.
- You got what?
- [Sarah] I got burned out.
- That makes sense.
That's awesome.
I think burnout's amazing and normal.
- [Sarah] Okay, well that's
good to hear (laughs).
- Listen to me, and listen to me good.
And this gonna be important for everybody.
Why are we judging
ourselves about yesterday?
Good, you got burnt out, which
is clearly what you needed,
because your burnout has fired
you up to get back to it.
- [Sarah] Yeah, yeah.
- Like why is it okay--
- [Sarah] So--
- Why is it okay, well
actually this is not okay.
By the way I've had a very
kind of like burnt out
first five months on my fitness and health
after four and a half
years of killing of it.
Like I made a decision.
I kind of looked how much it cost me
to travel these guys around
the world and finally decided,
"You know what I'm not sure I want
"to pay $2300 for a
workout, so I decided--
(laughing)
Yeah, anyway nonetheless,
I kind of said, "You know
what Jordan you don't have
"to travel with me this
year" like whatever.
And I completely lost my way.
Like I'm super fired.
I got real lucky, because
he was wrapping up,
in literally in a week.
Mike comes back, and it's going to be
Mike for three months,
Jordan for three months,
and so like mainly because
Mike was coming back
it bought me a little more time,
so like I've gone like
hard core drilled it
for four and a half
months, and have absolutely
not been on my game this year.
And I've really not been on my game
the last six to eight weeks,
and I'm definitely carrying
that extra eight pounds
I don't feel good about.
It's on my mind.
I'm sharing with you now, but
I'm not over judging that.
Like what?
I know I'm gonna get going
again, and it'll be awesome.
Don't judge your burnout.
- [Sarah] So what would
you do moving forward?
How do you connect with them and be like,
hey.
- Call them.
- [Sarah] Sorry I went MIA.
- [Sarah] Okay.
- Do what I'm doing with you.
- [Sarah] Yeah, no this is incredible.
This is so inspirational, because now
I want to call everybody (laughs).
- That's exactly right.
Call every fucking person.
How many customers you got?
- [Sarah] Gosh, not a whole lot.
- Give me the fucking answer.
- [Sarah] I don't know.
Probably like 50.
- Five zero?
- [Sarah] Five zero.
- Where are you right now?
What state?
- [Sarah] I'm in Pennsylvania.
- All right, east coast zone.
All right, by tomorrow night this time
you should call every single person.
- [Sarah] Okay.
- I'm telling you right
now I'm super intrigued
for you to do that.
Oh we have to call Victoria,
or what's her numebr.
Virginia; go find her number.
Sarah, you really need to call them all
by this time tomorrow.
I'm being dead serious.
- Okay.
- Happy Memorial Day.
Hope you're having a great weekend.
Hope you have a great weekend.
- [Sarah] Thank you.
- No, not you.
I'm telling--
(crew laughing)
I'm telling you what to tell them.
I mean I'd like you to have a nice
Memorial weekend today too, and by the way
you want to have a really
great Memorial day,
wait to you see what
you feel like waking up
Saturday morning after you call
these 50 people in the next 24 hours.
- [Sarah] Yeah, seriously.
That'll feel like I
really (audio cuts out).
- Do it right now.
Listen, you know what's crazy about this?
In the way that I answered it?
This morning was the first workout I had
that was kind of something
in a little while,
and it was bullshit, because
you start to lose your way.
Like little cardio stuff.
Jump rope and treadmill, and I feel great.
Like you--
- [Sarah] That's awesome.
- Listen to me everybody, and you, and me.
You can feel terrible
for 93 months in a row,
and execute properly today, and start
the process of feeling great.
You know how amazing that is?
- [Sarah] That is amazing.
- It doesn't count.
Life is more like boxing
than it is like basketball.
Basketball there's a record.
You're like 60 and 20, you know?
- [Sarah] Right.
- Boxing is you win this fight you win.
You can be 30-0 and you lose this fight
you're back to zero.
- [Sarah] Right.
- But you could win the next fight.
So just win today's fight.
Call everybody.
You better call at least
five people tonight.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- You're gonna call somebody right now.
- [Sarah] Okay, I can do it.
- All right, I love you, bye.
- [Woman] Roman from First Alliance says,
"The high tops are fire in the back."
- Yeah, these are fucking amazing.
I'm so fired up about this.
Wait, what's her number?
- [Man] 717--
- We're going to her?
Victoria?
It's Victoria or Virginia?
Virginia.
- Virginia.
- I always get confused.
Sorry, Andy.
Good job.
They are.
(dialing)
When are these dropping?
June when?
- [Man] June 10th.
- June 10th.
People are freaking--
- [Man] We'll network on the 28th.
- Network on the 28th global?
India too, because India's--
- [Man] Global.
- So that means India?
- [Man] Yes.
- India's freaking out about this.
Turkey's going nuts.
(crew laughing)
(line trilling)
Guys I've been pronouncing
Sinan's name wrong for 27 years.
(line trilling)
- [Man] Sinan?
- Sinan.
(laughing)
- I'm just gonna call him Sign on.
(line trilling)
What's her name?
Virginia?
- [Man] Virginia.
- Answer your fucking phone Virginia.
(line trilling)
I know you're ducking me Virginia.
- [Man] She's leaving comments.
- Saying what?
- She's like--
- [Voicemail] You have reached
Virginia Houzer of Greyhound Dog Training.
I am currently working
with a client right now.
If you could please leave your name,
phone number, and best time
to contact you I will reach
out to you as soon as possible,
- She's ready?
- [Voicemail] Or if you're interested
in scheduling a consultation please
go to GreyhoundDogTraining.com.
- She's been saying that she's mad
that I haven't got back to her?
But you don't think she's done it.
What's her name?
Virginia.
(laughing)
- [Voicemail] Thank you
and have a good day.
(beeping)
- Virginia, it's Gary.
Call me back.
(crew laughing)
Okay, let's go.
You like that, Andy?
- [Man] No, I had the comment.
Ready?
- Yeah, okay.
(crew laughing)
- [Man] This is Virginia the dog trainer.
I won't lie.
I'm a little hurt.
You never emailed me back.
After the episode I sent you updates,
but you're a busy guy, so I still love ya.
- I called her the next day.
- [Man] I know.
(line trilling)
You were with me, right?
- [Man] (speaks quietly)
need some motivation.
- Yo.
- [David] Hello?
(laughing)
- [David] Yo.
- David.
- [David] No way.
- Yeah, David it's Gary.
- [David] Get the fuck outta here.
- I'm staying, I apologize.
I'm gonna stay.
- [David] Dude!
- Yo.
- [David] Shit, no way.
Dude.
- Yes.
- [David] Honestly, I'm
like, "Wow, he's not even
"gonna call me."
- Well, no shit I'm not gonna call you.
I have like eight
thousand fucking numbers.
The odds were very low.
You should go play the lotto.
- [David] Yeah, I know I should.
I'm gonna go buy one right now.
- Let's go.
What can I answer for you?
- [David] Yo, so I wanted to ask you man;
I love all your videos.
- Thank you.
- [David] You really push me.
- [David] You. Drock, Bavin, everyone.
- Awesome.
- [David] You set fire every day man.
- I definitely do.
- I think Batman spits water.
- I freakn love it.
- But go ahead.
- [David] And...
I love everything that you say.
Everything that you
say is absolutely true,
but I just want to like you say,
"Just stop doing what you're
doing, and go do you."
- Got it.
- [David] That's what I want to do.
- I want you to do that too.
- [David] How do I do that?
How do I do that, because--
- Figure out why you're not doing.
It's either insecurity, or complacency...
or confusion.
There's a million reasons why it could be,
so what's your hot take?
What's the honest truth?
What do you want to be doing?
What are we talking about here?
- [David] Well, I want
to do is pretty much
like what DRock and Bavin
are doing right now.
- You want to film?
- [David] Yes, film and everything.
- Why don't you go work for
somebody for free for a year? -
[David] Okay.
- Good.
- [David] All right, I am gonna do that.
- And now you can do
what DRock and Bavin did.
Go work for free/minimum wage for a year.
Go find somebody who's a winner,
and a proven winner already
that you resonate with personality wise.
- [David] Okay.
- Hang up the phone right now,
and DM 100 people that
you look up to, and say,
"I want to work for
minimum wage to film you
like DRock and Bavin filmed Gary V.
Control + copy, control +
paste to a hundred people.
- [David] Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it for real.
Should I do that too like save up and--
- Schnel, in my office
just now on team Gary
just shook his head not
thinking you're gonna do it.
- [David] Okay.
- Why do you think he thinks that?
- [Man] He said, "Okay."
(laughing)
- [David] So just go ahead
and do it, right now?
- Well, yeah.
I think the thing, like
here's my question.
Why wouldn't you, and what
else would you be doing?
- [David] Honestly--
- Like spit it to me truthfully.
What would happen normally now
in the way that you like
I can see you're about to
open up, which I'm excited.
What would normally happen now?
You'd hang up, and what
would happen normally?
- [David] Okay, normally and
I'm being super duper honest.
- Yeah, dead ass.
I mean what are we doing here?
If you want to be happy
let me fucking help you,
but I need you to fucking
tell me the truth.
- [David] All right, so straight up.
I'm not even joking with you.
I'll probably go on YouTube right now,
and watch your videos,
and probably be like,
"Dude, this guy is saying the truth."
But you know what else
though I'd be doing,
or probably be watching
Hulu, or Netflix right now.
And just be fucking
watching just my own show.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay, I'm super insulted,
because what I expect
you to do right after this is hang up,
and fucking hit up all
your boys, and be like,
"Yo, I just fucking talked to Gary V!"
- [David] I will dude.
Not gonna lie.
I'm gonna do that like for real.
They're not gonna believe me.
But seriously why are you
not motivated for action?
Why are you just consuming shit?
- [David] See that's the thing.
I don't get it.
I was so motivated.
- Keep talking.
- I don't know.
I was even writing films...
and then I just stopped.
- And what happened?
Why?
- [David] I just stopped.
- Okay, are you fulfilled?
- [David] That's what I want to know.
- Let's talk.
- [David] Why the hell did I just stop?
- Well, are you happy-ish?
What are you doing?
- [David] Oh, hell no.
I'm not happy.
I just got laid off like last year
from my job at a bank.
And I've just been working side jobs.
And now I've been doing that
Flip life; Ebay Flip Life.
Made over $500 from boots I got for free.
- Okay.
- [David] Now I got a job at a clinic,
and I get paid like $10
an hour, which is shit.
But you know it's something.
- Listen, are you insecure?
Do you think can't do
what Bavin and DRock do?
Do you deep down, deep deep down know
that you can't film?
- [David] I feel like I have
the potential to do it--
- You're just not sure?
You're not sure?
- [David] Yeah, I feel like--
- I want to stick on this.
Are you just not sure?
You think you might, but
you're not sure, right?
Which makes sense.
I'm just curious.
- [David] Yeah, with
me I don't really want
to film from my phone.
I want to film from an actual camera.
- Why?
- [David] To look good.
For it to look good for me to like it,
and not just for me, but to
everyone to like it as well.
- But fucking iPhones are good.
- [David] That's true.
I take some dope ass
pictures from my iPhone.
I'm not gonna lie.
- Listen to me.
The camera quality is the quickest tell
for somebody who's full of shit.
- [David] Okay.
- And I'm saying that with love,
and I think you can tell.
- [David] Yeah.
- Listen to me.
There's some reason you don't want to do.
- [David] Yeah.
- Is hard work not fun?
Shoot it to me.
Tell me; it's okay.
- [David] Dude, not gonna lie man
people don't believe
me, but whatever it is
if you need me to do it I'll do it,
and I don't care about hard work man.
I will bust my ass.
- Then what about judgment
like peer pressure?
Like getting judged?
- [David] Oh yes, dude.
That 100%.
And I'm being serious, because
I want to do my own thing.
Like I said film, be in
movies, do at least something
with that, and then my mom's
like, "That's just fantasy."
And I even told her, "How is it fantasy?
"There's like thousands of
people doing it right now.
"How is that fantasy?"
It's not hard.
Well, it is hard probably,
but you can do it.
- Do you live with your mom?
- [David] Yeah.
- Move out.
- I live with my mom.
- [David] Okay.
(laughs) For sure man.
No joke.
- No, no, no, no.
Let's talk about it.
- Like for real.
- 'Cause we're going through this.
This is working from me.
- [David] Okay.
- How are you going to move out?
- [David] Well, I mean
the things that are going.
I was telling her too, I
just wanna sell everything
from my room, as much as
I can, get all that money.
- Good.
- [David] And get out.
- And what did she say?
- And honestly Gary, not gonna lie.
I got a 2001 Buick Century,
still runs to this day.
People are like dude, what
the hell is that type of car?
But let me tell you, I
keep up with that thing,
and that thing has gotten me everywhere.
- Love it.
- [David] And I have been using it
for going garage selling--
- Listen to me.
What you told your mom
You're gonna sell everything, and be out.
What did she say?
- [David] She just looked at me.
Well, she wants me to do it.
She's on both sides.
- Of course she's on both sides.
She's a parent.
- [David] Yeah, like--
- So what does she say this time?
- [David] For real not gonna lie.
She wants me to do my own thing.
She wants me to do that, but she wants
me to have a good stable job.
Suit and tie, actual government job.
But it's kinda like I told her too,
I want to be happy and do my own thing,
and she just doesn't believe in it.
- Listen to me.
- [David] Okay.
- You have to stop talking to her.
- You have to stop talking to everybody.
Sell all that shit.
Find a friend on Craigslist,
or find a high school friend,
or I don't fucking know.
Like move out.
Stop talking.
- [David] Okay.
- I don't understand
what we're doing here.
You're talking about it.
She wants you to.
She doesn't believe in your dream.
She wants you to fucking get a safe job,
because that's her framework.
- Exactly.
- You don't want to, so don't.
But move the fuck out.
Move the fuck out, and work for somebody
for 10 bucks an hours filming them.
- [David] There you go.
I'd rather do that.
- Where do you live?
- [David] I live in a small town
outside of San Antonio, Texas.
- Good.
Fucking find some San Antonio
fucking real estate person,
or some fucking entrepreneur.
There are at least 37
of those motherfuckers
looking up to Bavin and DRock, and me.
And fucking go.
- [David] Yeah, for real dude.
- I really just want you to do it.
- [David] Yeah, okay.
- Why haven't you moved out yet?
- [David] That's what I've
been telling myself too.
I graduated at 17.
How the hell am I still
here at this small ass town?
I want to leave.
But I don't know, I feel like--
- What are you scared of?
- [David] I'm not really scared of...
It's just what people
will think.
- You're very scared.
The end.
- [David] It's just
what people will think.
- Well, you live with your mom.
People are saying shit now.
- [David] That's true.
- So you crossed that chasm bro.
Stop fucking making pretend.
You crossed the chasm.
You live with your mom.
People are saying shit.
- [David] Right, right.
- Who's left?
- [David] Right, exactly
and honestly too, man,
I don't know, man.
It's just like I hate
living in this small town,
because I'm that skinny guy.
- So get on a fucking bus.
- [David] Okay, and just like get out?
Just like leave?
Straight up?
- No, stay in your mom's house forever.
Yes, get the fuck out.
- [David] Okay, for real.
- I think so.
You need to sleep somewhere.
Maybe you'll sleep in your
fucking 2001 fucking car.
- [David] Yeah, why not?
I mean it's--
- Logic lived
in his fucking car.
If you want to do it, do it.
You're worried about what your mom thinks.
You're worried about
what other people think.
Let me save you time.
Your mom thinks you're
fucking full of shit,
because you're still staying in the house,
and all you do is talk,
and all your friends
think you're a fucking loser,
'cause you live with your mom.
- [David] Exactly.
- Okay, what are we scared of now?
Everything you're scared
of already happened.
- [David] There you go.
- Everyone's shitting on you already.
You've been shit on.
There's no shit left.
- [David] Yeah.
- The thing that scares you happened.
Man.
- Uh-huh.
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- The thing you're scared of happened.
You're just bullshitting
yourself that it didn't happen,
and that's keeping you from getting happy.
- [David] That's true.
You know Gary, and too.
I'm being serious 'cause
like, even with my religion,
they don't even want us to
do shit the way we want.
- That's fine too, bro.
(overlapping chattering)
Religion, society, neighbors.
That's fine too.
Listen, I've nothing but
empathy and compassion.
Religion, households, the culture,
society, social media, your parents,
your fucking uncle, your grandparents.
Wait 'til your grandparents
die before you do that.
(speaks gibberish)
The fucking whole thing is that, bro.
- [David] Yeah.
You're right.
- I know I'm right.
I really, really think I'm right on this,
and I think the most interesting part
is the thing you're scared
of already happened.
- [David] Dude, I'm not gonna lie man.
I remember last year I went to L.A.
- I'm listening.
- [David] And my aunt said,
"Why don't you stay with me?"
- I'm listening.
- [David] And she's like,
"Why don't you stay with me?"
- And?
- [David] And that's the place
I've always wanted to live
was L.A.
- And, talk.
- [David] The only thing that
stopped me was my best friend.
- Okay, what about him or her?
- [David] The only thing is because
I don't want him to go alone.
I just don't want him to go alone
by himself back to his home.
- Home, where?
To San Antonio?
- [David] Yeah, to San Antonio.
- At the time you guys
were there together?
- [David] Right.
- 'Cause what was gonna happen?
He was gonna get punched in
the face when he walked in?
- [David] No, he's married and everything,
but him and I just went
on a trip together,
because I always wanted to go to L.A.
And like--
- That's sounds worse to me
than the iPhone camera story.
(David laughing)
Dude, you're fucking scared.
Do you understand me?
- Yes.
- You're fucking scared.
And the part that I'm most excited about
is the thing you're scared
of already fucking happened.
You know what the best thing
that ever happens to a young male?
They get punched in the
fucking face physically,
'cause they're never scared of it again.
They actually know what it is.
- [David] Yeah.
- You ever been punched
in the fucking face, Andy?
- Yeah.
- That's good.
- [David] Damn, Andy.
- Yeah, Andy's thug.
(crew laughing)
- [David] I've been elbowed in
the back of the fucking head.
Let me tell you, they regret doing that.
- Listen to me.
Listen to me.
You're scared.
- [David] You're right.
- About something that already happened.
- [David] All right, Gary.
I'm gonna start filming.
I've gotta get out of here.
- And, and?
- [David] I've gotta get out of here
and I'm gonna start DM-ing
right now, not gonna lie.
Once we get off this phone call
I'm gonna start DM-ing some photographers.
- Nope, you're gonna
start DM-ing entrepreneurs
and real estate agents.
- [David] Entrepreneurs, okay.
- And you're gonna say
I want to film you for 10 bucks an hour.
- [David] Okay.
- But now I want you to DM
people that live in Los Angeles.
- [David] Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
- Tell me why you're not
gonna do it after we hang up.
Tell me what's actually
gonna happen that's--
- [David] What do you mean?
I'm gonna do it (laughs).
- I'm asking you.
Listen, I'm not doing
this for show or content.
We're here, I content everything.
I'm here because I'm trying to figure out.
I'm playing here.
We're playing angles here.
Why won't you do that?
Why won't that happen
when we hang up here.
Like tell me.
- [David] Honestly, dude.
- Yes, honestly.
- [David] If we're being
honest, it's because my mom
is gonna be like, shut the fuck up,
and you're full of shit.
- If you do not--
- You won't do anything.
- Listen to me.
You're mom is fucking your shit up,
and you're fucking your shit up.
You need to get the fuck out of there.
- [David] Okay.
- You understand that, right?
- [David] Yeah, no really.
- On some real shit.
- [David] Yeah.
You're right, you're right,
'cause she has messed up most of my life.
She just believes that
I need a stable job.
- You let her mess it up bro.
You messed up.
You let her mess it up.
She's 49% of the equation.
You're 51.
- [David] Yeah.
- A lot of people have
fucked up moms, half.
- [David] Yeah.
- Some of them did something about it.
You're using it as your fucking excuse.
- [David] All right, all right.
- The second you stop blaming your mom,
even though she is wrong.
You notice what I did there?
You're understanding they're both true?
She is wrong.
- Correct.
- Until you take 100% responsibility
for being in that fucking house
doing nothing, you're doing nothing.
It's super easy to blame your mom.
- [David] Yeah.
- It's your fault.
You know what's fucked up.
- [David] Yeah.
- So let's go.
- [David] Okay, I really am.
- Listen to me, bro.
You've gotta get the
fuck out of that house.
- [David] I will dude.
For real though--
- Listen to me.
You need to get the fuck
out of that house, bro.
- [David] Okay.
- Get the fuck out of that house, bro.
- [David] Okay, I'm being serious.
- Live in your fucking friend's basement,
even though his wife will be pissed.
Fuck DM-ing.
Go to the airport and
fly to your aunt's house.
- [David] Dude, not gonna lie.
I really am thinking about
getting a one-way ticket to L.A.
Might as well, dude.
I mean I got--
- Alex doesn't think you're going to.
Alex just made a face.
Alex who fucking keeps it straight.
She said, "No, you're not."
I'm telling you, because
we're listening here.
- Gary--
- What's your Twitter handle?
Ready for this?
I want you to go live on Twitter right now
and go to the airport.
What's your Venmo?
I'm gonna Venmo you a $1,000
right now and I want you to--
- [David] No, Cash App me.
Cash App me.
- What?
What?
- [David] Cash App me.
- Listen to me.
- On Cash App.
- I heard him.
(crew laughing)
Listen to me.
Listen to me, we're gonna
make a deal right now.
I will Venmo you $1,000 right now,
but you have to livestream your ass
going to fucking the airport,
using it, and going to Los Angeles.
- [David] Okay.
- Okay, what?
- Okay.
- We're gonna recap right now.
If I Venmo you--
- First thing I need to do--
- What's that?
- [David] First thing I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna set up a Venmo,
'cause I don't have it.
(Gary laughing)
- You have a PayPal?
- And then--
- You got a PayPal?
- [David] Yes, I have PayPal.
- Let's go.
- [Andy] Round trip is 500 bucks.
- 500, I'm giving him an extra 500 Andy.
- Okay.
(crew chatting)
- Oh, he needs a one-way.
One-way Andy.
What time is the flight?
- [David] Dead ass.
Bet, bet.
Because I promise you I'm gonna
go to my car and fill it up.
You know what,
I'm just gonna tell my buddy
yo drop me off at the airport.
- Yeah, you don't need
that fucking car no more.
- [David] Okay, I'm
gonna do it straight up.
I'm gonna start packing right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
- I believe you.
Hold on, I want to see what
flight we're putting you on.
What time is it in San Antonio right now?
- [David] Okay, it's
actually 7:41 right now.
- All right, what do we got Andy?
- [Andy] There's a flight at 7:55.
- He's not gonna be able to make that.
- [David] No, I'm not gonna make it.
Andy, can you find like
an eight something,
or almost nine?
(crew laughing)
- Hold on, there's a 9:55.
We got you.
- That's a.m.
- Oh, a.m.
- [David] Damn it, Andy (laughs).
- What about 8:55?
8:55, we got you, bro.
8:55
- 8:55, I swear to God.
- [Andy] 8:55 non-stop Thursday, May 23rd.
- [David] I'm getting dressed.
- [Andy] LAX.
- Let's go SouthWest, let's go.
What's your PayPal?
- SouthWest!
- Tyler where's my PayPal?
- [Tyler] I got it.
- What's your PayPal, bro?
- [David] Okay, you wanna
know my PayPal for real?
Because I'm getting dressed
right now, I'm not gonna lie.
- I hear you, I'm excited.
- [David] I'm leaving man.
- I'm about to change your fucking life.
- Dude, no lie.
- This is it.
- Dude, oh my god.
You better call you aunt on the way.
- [David] I'm wearing my
Logic jersey and everything.
- What?
- [David] I'm wearing my
Logic jersey and everything.
- Let's go.
- [David] Okay, all right,
so here's my PayPal.
- Tyler, you ready?
Here's the PayPal.
Go ahead.
- [David] Okay, okay.
Okay, it's sonnyjim5.
S-O-N-N-Y.
- S-O, go ahead.
- J-I.
Okay, S-O-N-N-Y.
- Go ahead.
- J-I-M.
Sonny Jim.
- [David] Yeah, five; the number five.
- I know five.
- [David] Okay, @yahoo.com.
- Yahoo?
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
@yahoo.com.
(crew laughing)
All right, how much is that flight?
You got an 8:55 bro.
You're gonna have to move.
- [David] Okay, dude I'm already
getting dressed right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
- I believe you.
- [David] All right,
I'm gonna call my boss--
- Fuck it, I said, "I'm
gonna send him $1,000."
Send him $1,000.
I'm sending you a
thousand fucking dollars.
I think the flight's like $140,
so you can fucking take an Uber
to the fucking Four Seasons
tonight in L.A. and fucking go.
- [David] Oh my fucking
god, dude not gonna lie;
I'm using it.
- Now real quick.
What's his Twitter?
Bro, here's the key though,
because I'll ruin your life.
I'll find some Russian mafia
people to take you out.
I need you to go now.
- I believe it.
I believe it.
- The flight might be sold out.
- The flight sold out?
- Maybe.
Yeah, it's not opening up.
- [David] Don't do this
to me Bavin, or Andy.
(crew laughing)
Andy, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm a little too excited here.
- No, honestly now we're
canceling the whole thing.
Now that you did that to Andy
we have to cancel this whole thing.
- [David] No, no.
no, no dude.
- I'm kidding.
- [David] I was already going.
- They got the 5:40 tomorrow morning.
- No, no, he's going on a flight tonight.
I don't give a fuck if this motherfucker
has to sleep in the airport
and live stream the whole time
he's leaving his fucking house right now.
What?
- Yo, Andy--
- You sent it?
- Andy, I'm so sorry.
I apologize, but I'm being dead serious.
I'm already packing right now.
- Hey, bro listen to me.
- [David] What's up?
- Tyler just hit the button.
You got $1,000 in your
PayPal from me right now.
- [David] Get the fuck outta here!
- It's real.
- Oh my god.
- Okay?
- [David] Okay.
- What?
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah that's his name.
- Thank you.
- Listen to me.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so
much, but listen to me.
- [David] Okay.
- I need you to go live
on fucking Twitter.
- [David] How do you go, okay.
- You figure it the fuck out!
- [David] Okay, I'm gonna figure it out.
- It's called Google, and
when you get to the airport,
there's no flight; you'll figure it out.
The days of relying on
your mother are over.
It is now Google.
- Okay.
- Google is your mother.
(crew laughing)
- [Man] Put that on a T-shirt.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- You don't have an answer
you go to fucking Google.
- [David] That's right, that's right.
- All right, this--
- [David] I'm taking
your shoes with me, Gary.
- That's a good idea.
(crew laughing)
It's DavidLH9708 for everybody
who's watching right now,
'cause we're all gonna watch him do this.
- [David] Yes.
Dude, I'm already leaving to
the airport; not gonna lie.
I'm already packing.
- That's fine.
DavidLH9708.
- [David] Okay.
- He's a traveler who's never
left his mom's fucking home.
(crew laughing)
- [David] I should have
stayed in fucking L.A.,
but hey I wouldn't have talked
to you right now, if I did.
- Of course not.
Dude, that's why it
turned out to be better,
and by the way you couldn't stay in L.A.
You had to go back to San
Antonio with your best friend,
so you could walk him into his
house with his fucking wife.
- [David] Yo, dude I'd rather
just stay in L.A., and--
- You're staying in L.A. dick.
What do you mean rather stay?
You are staying, you live in L.A. now.
David, you live in fucking L.A.
- [David] Shit, man.
Damn!
- Yes!
(crew laughing)
This is how it happens.
How much is a hostel in L.A.?
- [Woman] It's like 50 bucks a night.
(crew chatting)
- What's that?
- [Woman] He can go to his aunt's house.
Call his aunt.
- I mean, he's gonna live with his aunt,
you're calling your aunt of course?
- [David] Yeah, yeah, oh,
well I mean that's gonna be a surprise.
Let me tell you that much.
- Let me tell you what the real
surprise is gonna be David.
The amount of people in L.A. right now
that are gonna be
hitting you up on Twitter
telling you that you can stay with them.
- [David] Yo, I believe it.
- You have a family now.
- [David] Yep.
- [Woman] He's got 20 roommates on here.
- DavidLH9708 is his Twitter handle.
He's about to go live.
He's gonna figure it out,
'cause his new mother's name is Google.
- [David] Yo, hell yeah!
- [Andy] Hostels are 40 bucks a night.
- [David] Oh, you should see me bro.
- What are you doing?
- [David] I'm already packing up dude.
- Well, I can't see you fucking
live streaming on Twitter.
All I see is you're a traveler.
- [David] All right,
you really are gonna see
some traveling right now, not gonna lie.
(Gary laughing)
- Listen to me.
David, listen to me.
You need to stop packing.
Well, actually pack, because I want
you to get to the airport.
You don't think there's a
flight in San Antonio, huh?
We're about to finally
see what David's gonna do.
David's about to have some billionaire
fucking fly him private from (laughs).
(crew laughing)
- [David] Yo, I'm not gonna lie man.
Okay, so did y'all find a flight for me
if not I can just use my 1,000 bucks
and just buy a ticket.
- David,
your mother is Google.
You're asking Andy to become your mother.
I need you to become your mother.
You and Google.
Do you understand, we're
not finding shit for you.
I gave you a fucking $1,000.
- [David] Yeah, that's what I just said.
I already was gonna get the 1,000 bucks,
and I'm already gonna use it
right now to buy a ticket.
- Let's go.
Now, one thing I'm impressed
with is March 16th, a week ago,
or no a couple months ago I do like
that you found that Hasbro
Gi Joe tank for a dollar,
and sold it for $10.60.
- [David] Right.
- That's good.
- [David] Yo, dude you
should've seen me, man.
First time I went to L.A.
you came a week later.
I'm like this fucker, man.
What the hell, but hey
this is even better.
This is even better.
- Of course it's better I
gave you $1,000 to move out
of your fucking shit house situation
to move to L.A. and change your life.
That would have been better
than the one second selfie
we took at the fucking K-Swiss store.
- [David] Yo, watch man,
my mom is gonna be like, no, no, no.
But I'm gonna be like, sorry, mom.
Love you.
- You're not telling her, bro.
Virginia's calling.
(crew laughing)
Bro, I gotta go.
Virginia's calling.
See ya.
(line trilling)
Hello?
- [Virginia] Hey, Gary, it's Virginia.
- It's good to hear from you Virginia.
How are you?
- [Virginia] I'm great.
- I'm great, I'm just checking in.
- [Virginia] Yeah, yeah (laughs),
you caught me in the middle of a session.
I was signing a contract with a family.
- Good for you.
You caught me in a session of
giving some kid in San Antonio
with a fucked up mom $1,000
to move to Los Angeles,
and change his life.
- [Virginia] Oh, shit.
Nice.
- Yeah.
(crew laughing)
So what's going on with you?
- [Virginia] Oh, nothing much.
I'm doing my thing.
- What does that mean?
Did we quit, or no?
Tell me the truth.
- [Virginia] No, I didn't quit, Gary.
- I understand.
Did we come close?
How long did the high from
the call I'm quitting last?
Where did we get?
How far did we get?
- [Virginia] Honestly,
the high from the call
lasted a few hours.
And don't get me wrong I haven't
lost the high of quitting.
- What happened?
- [Virginia] What we
didn't get to talk about
during the call was I already
have a plan for an out.
I have an end game.
(phone beeps)
Like July 10th, I'm
putting in my two weeks,
and July 24th, I'm done.
- Okay, I will call you back on July 10th.
- [Virginia] That sounds perfect to me.
- Have a great Memorial Day.
- [Virginia] You too, man.
Take care.
- Bye bye.
(line ringing)
All right.
(crew laughing)
A lot going on.
(crew chatting)
What's that?
- [Woman] What are you gonna
do if he doesn't go to L.A.?
- We'll figure it out.
(line trilling)
- [Andy] Is he live on Twitter yet?
- [Woman] No.
- [Daina] Hello?
- Hello, it's Gary.
- [Daina] Hi Gary!
- Hi.
- [Daina] It's so great to hear you.
I'm Daina and my fiancee,
Adam is here with me.
- Hi.
- What's up Daina and Adam?
- [Daina] How are you, my friend?
- I'm super well.
How are you?
- [Daina] I'm fantastic.
My heart is beating out
of my chest a little bit.
- That's good.
- But--
- Is your fiancee okay with that?
- Yes. (laughs)
(crew laughing)
- [Adam] Yeah, no we're totally fine.
We're just very excited
to be actually speaking to you in person.
- I love it.
What can I help you guys with?
- [Daina] Well, you help us everyday.
I mean I introduced Adam
to you and your platform.
We were literally name
dropping you today at dinner
at True Food Kitchen
at the Boca Town Center
to our lovely waitress, Alexa,
and she's an awesome
chick, and I was like,
"Hey, do you know who Gary Vaynerchuk is?"
Am I saying it right?
- Yeah.
- And yes?
- You're saying it right.
- [Daina] And she was talking about how...
Say it again.
- No, I thought you asked
me was I saying it right.
I was saying yes.
- [Daina] Okay, thank you.
Thank you (laughs).
So, she was saying how she wants
to move to Bali or something,
but she doesn't have
the money, and I'm like,
"Well, don't you know
what Gary would say?"
He would say, "And?"
(Gary laughing)
And?
- And how did she take that?
- [Daina] She took it.
She was great.
- I love it.
- [Daina] She's gonna
follow me on Instagram,
and I told her about
another friend of mine
that's an influencer in a
different realm than yours.
- Got it.
- [Daina] But an influencer none the less.
- Yep.
- And it's just amazing.
I have your Clouds & Dirt
shoes, the female version.
I wear it to the airport,
and some kid saw it.
He was like, "Hey, those are Gary V's."
I'm like, "Yep."
- That's awesome.
- [Daina] So, we're already subscribing
to your Empathy Wines.
- You're amazing.
- [Daina] We had your Rose and loved it.
- Thank you.
- [Daina] We're looking
forward to getting...
You're welcome.
- You guys are very sweet.
Can I answer something for you guys,
'cause you're just flattering
me, which is beautiful,
but I want to bring you value.
- [Daina] Yeah, well the
value is I actually want
to be a part of your team in some way.
- Okay.
- If you ever need something
in Florida we're here in Delray Beach.
I spread your...
I don't what to say when you say your...
- Gospel.
- [Daina] Your gospel, yeah.
Thank you, I was looking
for the right word.
And I never really want anything back
from it other than trying to be part
of making the world more
with Gary V love, and--
- You're very sweet.
Well, that's very sweet.
I'm so glad I got you guys on the phone.
- [Adam] Hey, and since I'm here
and I'm new to this whole Gary V world.
- Yes sir.
- I'm gonna throw you
a question.
- Please.
- [Adam] Because a lot of what you say
to some people seems matter of fact,
but at the same time there's
always that mental block.
Well, yeah I kinda get what he's saying,
but I can't do that,
because of x, and y, and z.
- Yeah.
- [Adam] There's always that roadblock,
so for those that have
that roadblock and go,
I don't know if that's for me?
How do you respond to that, and say,
of course it's for you.
It's for everybody.
- Yeah, so that's a great question.
Listen, the two words
that scare me the most
are but and because when they
consume my content right.
Those two b-words scare the fuck outta me.
They scare me, because I
know that it's grounded
in insecurity, and I need to figure out...
The reason I consistently
put out so much content
is that I know the only way for me
to actually achieve
impact is a scary level
of consistency, and
creativity in perpetuity.
So what do I say to them?
I'll see you tomorrow.
- Right.
- Right, 'cause you
never know what version
of the same thing you've
always been saying teamed up
with the right moment in time leads
to the first movement of action.
- [Daina] Yep.
- [Adam] And that's
actually right on point.
- Yeah, it's just I can't
be ideological about it.
I know that we're all on different paths.
I'm ambitious on actually
having this impact and legacy
thus I have to be focused on consistency.
It's really meta.
Like what I'm actually up
to and trying to achieve,
I'm actually doing, which is what
I'm telling everybody else to do.
I'm staying patient.
I'm staying consistent.
- [Daina] Yeah, stay the course.
I get it.
I actually had to reset
my Facebook password,
so I'm not even on the live right now,
and I'm trying to get (laughs).
(Gary laughing)
- Don't worry it's being recorded.
You'll be able to watch it
eating some popcorn later.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Awesome.
- All right guys.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
You're welcome.
- Thank you for everything.
- Bye bye.
A lot going on in here.
Virginia still working.
- [Man] Another scary word was
past that you talked about.
- What's that?
- [Man] The other scary word
you talked about was past.
- Yeah, I hate a lot of words.
- [Man] You're gonna get into
some family dynamics again.
- But and because.
(line trilling)
But and because, man.
But I can't do it because--
- [Man] Oh.
- Yep.
(crew laughing)
Yep, yep, yep.
- [Brian] Oh, snap.
- Yep, Brian it is true.
- [Brian] No way.
Yo, oh my god.
I'm good.
- You know why I called you?
- [Brian] Why?
- Because you have five followers,
and five is my favorite number.
(crew laughing)
- [Brian] Oh shit (laughs).
I can't believe this.
That's crazy.
- It's real bro.
- [Brian] Wow, I don't
want to waste your time,
but first off, thank you so
much for everything you give.
So, I want to let you
know basically real quick.
Thank you for putting Reezy on.
Where you do resells on.
- Yep, yep.
- [Brian] And the reason
why I'm telling you that
is because I was in such a crossroads
because I worked in a corporate job,
and it's good.
I do it for my parents,
and he was talking about reselling,
and from that day on to now
it's been crazy with Ebay and Amazon.
I mean I'm walking to work
a little differently now.
So.
- With a little more leverage on you side.
- Yeah, leverage.
(phone beeps)
Yeah, exactly, more leverage,
and it's just crazy
how it changed my life.
- Makes me super happy, bro.
Listen the Flip Life is very,
very, very fucking real,
and I've got my version of it.
- It is.
- Which is like fun, and exciting,
but Reezy and others are showing people,
and there's many other
great voices out there
like showing people scalable shit.
And honestly bro I may do
one episode of Trash Talk
where I just buy everything
at every garage sale,
and actually just show people
how actually ludicrous it is,
because almost everything's--
- It is, yeah.
- Worth more money.
I'm just doing the stuff
that gets me going.
Dude, I left $150 Yankee
jacket right next to
the Jets jacket on purpose--
- Yeah, I saw that.
- To see how many people saw it.
Like on purpose, and then
I read all the comments,
and like three people saw it.
- [Brian] Yeah (laughs).
No, I saw that.
I saw it.
I didn't comment, but I saw it (laughs).
- Because you're like, ah, I love Gary,
but I don't want to raz him.
Like I'm not scared.
You can raz.
(Brian laughing)
- Yeah, anyways--
- I can fucking take it.
(Brian laughing)
- [Brian] But anyways I wanted
to just ask you real quick--
- Go.
- [Brian] Potentially, what happened was
I'm doing reselling on the side.
- Yes.
- [Brian] And I've been using that money
to pretty much put that money
into my family's business.
- Good.
- And so what we do,
it's a family restaurant,
Vietnamese restaurant.
My parents had a really
big restaurant in Tampa,
and they downsized in a very small area.
- Yep.
- [Brian] And essentially,
we've been doing a lot
of Facebook marketing.
- Yep.
- [Brian] And I remember
having a lot of fights
with my dad about how he doesn't
believe in it and yada yada yada.
- Yep.
- [Brian] And obviously
now he's like (laughs)
when the news channel actually
asked us to get on TV.
Now he's like, "Wow, we shouldn't do it,
"because no one's even watching TV,"
(laughs) so the whole
time it's been flipped.
His mindset's been flipped, but now
I'm doing more with influencer marketing.
Just because you've been talking
about how under priced it it is.
- Yes.
- And it's so real.
- I tend to be right.
- It's just so real.
Yeah (laughs).
And the thing is--
- I tend to be right,
because I don't talk about shit
until I've proven it to myself.
I'm not out here guessing.
I'm not here trying to give any
of you fuckers ammo to say I'm wrong.
I'm talking about shit
that I already fucking did.
- [Brian] Yeah, yeah.
No, you're right, and the
thing is it's been working.
Okay, so I know one thing I would want
to ask you is basically
what our restaurant,
and tends to...
It's such a small area.
How do you know which followers,
I guess it's very tactical here,
but how do you know which followers
or influencers is worth messaging,
because I've been dealing
with a lot of influencers
that you could tell
there's fake followers,
and because it's not
like an online business
where you just hit up anybody
that is within that field;
there's a little bit smaller radius.
So what would your suggestion be?
- Go after alpha moms in the area.
Don't go after influencers.
Go after normal people that
actually live in the area,
because all their followers
are from the area.
- [Brian] Right, even if it's
under 1,000 and all that?
- Would you rather have
somebody who has 430 followers,
but they happen to be 200 residents
that live close to your restaurant,
or would you rather have somebody,
who has 10 million followers,
and only 16 are in that area?
- [Brian] Yeah, you're right.
Yeah.
Cool.
Well, yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking,
but I just want to make sure (laughs).
- Great.
- [Brian] Well, thanks Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Brian] Love you, man.
- I love you more.
- Seriously thank you so much.
- Bro, if you find anymore
weird rare Jets shit
at a garage sale I want it.
- [Brian] (laughs) I will.
I will get you some.
- You got it.
That's actually a great call to arms.
Anybody who's flipping, garage selling,
if you happen to find some crazy ass shit.
(line trilling)
- [Man] Normal people
with accents in the area,
because it's all their
followers in the area.
- Hello?
- [Man] Hello.
- [Man] Right, even with--
- That was weird as shit.
(crew laughing)
I feel like.
It's over.
You got it?
Call.
This is fun.
I fucking could do this all day
for the rest of my fucking life.
- [Woman] (speaks quietly)
moms are the key to life.
- The person that raises you
is the key to fucking life
in a way that you can't imagine,
and then the other key to life
is the outside voice that penetrates you,
which is pro or con to that.
And that's what I'm doing, right?
That's what makes it so exciting.
You know what I think about?
What I'm up to?
It's more like being a rock band
in the '70s, or an early hip-hop band.
You get to kids at 14, 15, 16,
and you're like the first thing
that can get them out of their framework.
(line trilling)
But it was all like sex, drugs, and rock.
It's all that stuff.
So, I'm trying to like, how do I do this?
- [Andy] Josh.
- Hey, Josh.
- [Josh] Gary, what's up, bud?
- Life is great, Josh.
How are you?
- [Josh] I'm doing well, man.
- Super duper.
What can I help you with?
- [Josh] Hey, man, so my girlfriend wanted
to know what's the true
value of an internship?
- The value is the people
that you actually meet
there that later on put you on.
- [Josh] Cool, so like
the connections you make?
- It has nothing to do
with learning anything,
'cause you won't.
Let me rephrase.
It's highly unlikely you'll
learn a whole, whole lot.
You may get super duper lucky,
and find the right kind of company.
Let's call it 20%, which is a nice number
where you do learn something,
but even if you're learning,
even like I'm watching my team
where I think people are really learning,
if I just think about it.
I'm looking at all the faces.
You can learn quite a
bit in the first 60 days,
but man there's a lot to learn.
You know what I mean?
I'm saying you can get a lot.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- What is disproportionately
valuable is the relationships.
- [Josh] Got you, got you.
Find those connections, right?
- A thousand percent, bro.
Life is about people.
- [Josh] I got you, man.
I got you.
- Got it?
- I really appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much.
- You got it.
Take care.
I like Josh.
Came in.
Boom.
Boom, boom.
Boom!
Let's go, Andy.
Andy's a little slow.
He was expecting a little
bit of a longer call,
and got caught with the off-speed pitch.
It's Brian again.
What's everyone saying?
Is it good?
Did people like it?
- Yeah.
- How many followers
did what's his name get?
He went from 16 to?
- [Woman] Almost at a thousand.
He went from 100--
- He had 500.
- Oh, he had 500.
- No, he had 1116.
116.
- 116.
- [Woman] 116.
- And he got to 1,000 followers that fast?
- [Woman] He's at 900 right now.
- [Man] 1,000 followers,
and 1,000 bucks all in the same night.
- [Woman] 8:30.
- He's probably laying in his fucking bed.
(crew laughing)
Mom, guess what.
I got 1,000 followers, and 1,000 bucks.
(crew laughing)
That motherfucker better
be going to the airport.
(line trilling)
He's not live yet.
- [Paulo] Hello?
- [Andy] Paulo.
- Paulo, it's Gary V.
- [Paulo] No fucking way.
- Yes sir.
- [Paulo] No.
- Yes.
- [Paulo] I'm using two phones right now.
One to contact you, and
one to watch your stream.
- Double fisted.
- [Paulo] And I was
just watching David LH.
- Yes.
- And he's not popping.
There's no live or anything.
- You're fucking pissed, right?
- [Paulo] I'm pissed.
- 'Cause you're saying, motherfucker,
if I would have gotten that
shot I'd be live as shit!
- [Paulo] I was waiting for $1,000,
then someone's gonna call him back
and if someone can live with
him, and start a new life,
but he's not...
- You're upset with David.
(crew snickering)
- [Paulo] Yes, but I have a question.
I always watch your videos,
and there's times where you say
that people that have been given to them,
like materialistic.
- Yes.
- [Paulo] They're at a disadvantage.
- They are.
- [Paulo] And it be like
I'm on that side, because.
- Okay.
- [Paulo] I might not be spoiled, but.
- That means you're spoiled.
Yeah, you're spoiled.
- [Paulo] And my question
is how do I remove myself?
- Stop taking shit.
- Or start from the bottom?
- [Paulo] Yes, that's what happening.
- Good.
- [Paulo] Because I'm a senior
in high school right now,
and I told my dad, "Dad, from now on
"don't give me anything materialistic.
"Just give me advice.
"Don't give me anything that--
- I'm proud of you, bro.
That's fucking hard.
Dude, I really admire you.
Do you know how hard that is?
- Dude, no, 'cause he told me,
"Paulo when you live life,
"people will take shit from you,
"but no matter what if it's in your head
"they can't take it away.
"They can take you car.
"They can burn it down.
"People can still from you--
- That's good.
- [Paulo] "But they
can't steal the knowledge
"that's in your head."
- That's a great point by your dad too.
- [Paulo] And I don't have the
feeling of going to college,
'cause I'm pursuing the freedom
of not working nine to five.
- Okay.
- [Paulo] But in order to
do that I need to work hard.
- No shit, very good.
I like everything coming out of your math.
- [Paulo] But there's times
where I do watch your videos,
and when I'm done I don't
have the motivation,
but if I do I lose it,
or maybe it's because what
you're saying is I'm spoiled,
and what I'm trying to say
is I need to find where I'm by myself,
and that's why I decided to move in
by myself and with my dog.
- How are you paying for that apartment?
- [Paulo] I already applied.
I live in (speaks quickly).
It's up north in New York,
and I'm graduating high
school in about three weeks.
But right now I'm working
as a part-time job.
- Okay.
- [Paulo] But as soon as
I graduate I'm gonna work
two full-time jobs, then when
I come home I'm gonna hustle,
and look for something that
I really have passion for.
- That's amazing dude.
I'm super fucking--
- [Paulo] But, because you said,
to getting where you are
you need to do the full-time job,
because there's no other way.
- If you don't go to college
and get the kind of degree
that gives you leverage to
get the kind of job you want
what's gonna end up happening--
- [Paulo] I could do a two
year as a nurse, then use that.
- Do you want to be a nurse?
- [Paulo] But I don't
know if I want to do that?
- You don't want to do that.
- [Paulo] I know, but what you say is,
"I won't know until you try."
- Right.
- [Paulo] When I told my dad,
"Paulo, you're wasting a year."
I'm like dad, I watch this guy.
Hell, even if I waste,
let's say I wasted a year.
It's not a waste, because now I know that.
At least I tried.
I didn't waste like 40
years and I blame my dad,
'cause he stopped me
from doing what I wanted.
Even if I fail, I'd rather
fail than not do it.
- Paulo, you're gonna make me wanna
do this for the rest of my life.
Like everything coming out
of your makes a ton of sense,
and I'm really impressed.
- [Paulo] I hate regret, Gary.
- Me, too brother.
- [Paulo] You can't hate regret.
- I'm with you on that one, man.
I feel like you're Gary V, and I'm Paulo.
(crew laughing)
- [Paulo] No, no, no, no,
Not even.
Bro, you don't even know,
I'm shaking right now.
I'm in my bed, because
I was just watching you.
Then the David LH blew up.
I was like, holy shit.
It says New York, and I'm like, fuck!
(crew laughing)
I'm shaking right now, but--
- Can I ask you a question?
Can I ask you a question?
- [Paulo] Go ahead.
- Is your dad impressed with the things,
and the thoughts that he--
- [Paulo] No, he loves it,
but he tells me, "Paulo."
He tells me all the time,
"What are you doing with your 24 hours?"
I'm like, "Yes, I understand.
"I'm on my phone."
He's right, because there's 24 hours.
There's eight hours of me in school,
then I work a part-time job.
I leave at school from 12 afternoon,
then from 4:30 to 8:00 I work everyday.
- Impressed.
- [Paulo] I told my dad, "Dad,
I want to pay for my car.
"I want to pay for my bills.
"I want to pay for everything,
"'cause I don't want to be that kid."
'Cause we moved from Philippines,
and just by doing that.
Because there's no way if I
was in the Philippines right now working,
there's no way I could get a car,
but because he moved there,
and he worked hard, and
he brought us to America.
I have the opportunity to
actually do what I wanna do.
- Paulo, I fucking believe in you.
I don't know what else to say.
I love every fucking thing
that's coming out of your mouth.
- [Paulo] I know, but like there's
one thing that I hate in my life where--
- Okay.
- [Paulo] I could do
it, but for some reason
there's either like the being comfortable
that's why I want to move into my own,
'cause after that there's
no help from my mom,
there's no help from my dad,
my safety fund will be gone,
so I can't fuck around.
Like I have to do--
- Good.
- [Paulo] What I have
to do or I'm gonna fail.
- That's great.
So, enjoy your next
three weeks of vacation,
and then get the fuck to work.
That's how I thought about
school at this point.
I was like, this is vacation.
Let me suck it all up,
'cause I'm about to go on for 80 years.
- [Paulo] Like right
now I'm telling myself,
oh, I'll only start to work
hard when I'm by myself.
- You're about to find out.
Here's the good news.
If you go and do this, and it's on you.
Two jobs to pay rent, and
you start fucking around,
and go to one job, and watch fucking--
- [Paulo] No, no, no.
Because now I'm doing that,
I have let go of my phone.
Oh my god the mug life, Gary.
Oh shit, I found like Winnie the Pooh,
1997 winter edition.
I bought it for like...
They were selling it for $4.
I was like, "Can I buy 12 of them for $1?"
And they gave me all of them,
and I would sell them for $20 on LeGo.
- I'm fucking proud of you, bro.
- But not only that--
- Wait, real quick.
You bought those 12 Winnie the Pooh mugs
for a dollar each for 12 bucks?
- [Paulo] Yes, for $12.
- And sold them for fucking $240?
- [Paulo] But not only that
I sold each of them for $20.
- And sold them all?
- [Paulo] Yes, not only that
I would tell them, I said I'm
living in (speaks quickly)
and they're like, I'm in (speaks quickly).
I was like, if you want to pick it up,
no, if you want me to
bring it to you, add $15.
And they would add $15,
and I would get $35
for just me buying a $1 of a
mug in like a Saturday morning.
- I understand, Gary.
(crew laughing)
- [Paulo] I can't...
Hello?
- Yeah, I'm here.
(crew laughing)
- [Paulo] No, 'cause I
hear feedback I'm sorry.
- It's not feedback, bro.
It's fucking pride.
I'm fucking happy as fuck about you.
- [Paulo] You don't even know.
This will be on YouTube.
I can watch it later.
- Yes, you can.
- [Paulo] Oh my god, wait
but how do I kill that?
- Kill what?
- [Paulo] Kill the procrastination,
or kill the being comfortable, because--
- You're about to find out.
It sounds like you have
a very specific plan.
You got three weeks of vacation,
and you're gonna try to kill it--
- [Paulo] No, it's not vacation.
It's three weeks of school left.
- I'm calling it fucking vacation.
Stick with me.
- [Paulo] Oh Jesus.
Okay, go ahead.
- So, three weeks of school AKA vacation.
Enjoy the fuck out of it.
Get anything out of your mind.
Lay it all on the field now.
That girl you've liked
for all three years,
go say something.
- [Paulo] Huh?
- The girl that you've liked
for the last three years
in high school and haven't
said shit to, go say something.
- [Paulo] No, bro we broke
up, but I'm fine with that.
(crew laughing)
I moved on.
- All right, respect.
Respect.
- [Paulo] It doesn't matter at this point,
'cause she's not gonna help me.
I'm on my own.
- Let's go.
On your own is good, bro.
It's good,
I'm excited.
- Yeah, I know.
I've been stopping.
My friends are like,
Paulo, why are you too
picky with your friends?
I'm like, I never have
one that's actually good
that I'm interested in saying
what's up man and not actually know them.
Like, go fuck yourself.
- Your prerogative.
I like both.
- [Paulo] Yes, yes.
But you're telling me
just to wait, just use--
- Three weeks?
Three weeks I'm good with.
Everything I just heard,
the maturity at 17.
The level of conversation.
- I'm 18.
- 18, the level of
conversation with your dad.
You're fucking flipping.
You're about to get two fucking jobs
to have you and you're fucking dog.
I'm fucking pumped, bro.
- [Paulo] I know, 'cause
I was like I can't leave,
'cause my dad doesn't want the dog.
- So take the fucking dog.
- I'm connected to the dog,
so I was like oh I have to get
an apartment that has a dog.
- That's fine.
They have those.
- [Paulo] I know, I know, I know.
But, yeah--
- Bro, you got this.
- [Paulo] Oh my god, I can't believe you.
Holy shit.
I've been like commutating
my phone number for the last hour.
- Well, you tricked Andy.
Good job.
- [Paulo] Oh yeah, Andy
you're doing a good job.
Don't listen to David.
(crew laughing)
- All right, bro, good luck.
- [Paulo] Oh my god, yes.
You made my night.
Holy shit.
Have a good--
- You too.
- Have a good night guys.
- You too, you too, bye.
I like that kid.
It's crazy to hear the difference
of something that's, right.
I'm just looking at you guys.
Like the difference between
somebody that's seeing it,
and the one that's not seeing
it, and you can see it.
Man, that was a super mature conversation.
That felt really good to me.
- [Woman] Person online started
a hashtag, where is David?
(crew laughing)
(line trilling)
- Cory.
- Hello?
- Cory, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Corey] Holy shit.
- Yes sir.
- [Corey] Hi.
- Hi, How are you?
- [Corey] Doing good, how about you?
- Super good.
- [Corey] This is crazy.
I've been watching for like two years now,
and it's super cool to talk to you.
- Thank you, what can I help you with?
- [Corey] So, I'm starting this job
in like two to three weeks,
and I've really been upset
for a long time with kind
of like how people work.
One of the things I've noticed a lot
is like managers tend to like micro manage
how you work, and they tend to focus
on like well let people be in their zone,
and what really motivates
them to do their work.
And so I'm wondering.
- I couldn't agree more.
- [Corey] How do I change people's minds?
How do I get managers to
kinda back off people,
and kinda let them live in their space.
I'm starting this new
job at Dell so like--
- You communicate it to them.
It's highly unlikely
they'll listen to you,
and you move on when you don't
find the manager that you like.
- [Corey] How do I be that
person for other people,
'cause I'm kinda going to that space
to where I want to do--
- You're going into a place
where you don't have the leverage,
so you've gotta be
thoughtful about that, right?
Your ideology is right.
Your ability to execute on that ideology
doesn't exist upfront
unless you're persuasive
in your communication to a
manager as a new employee.
- [Corey] So, how long should
I like shut up and kinda,
I should just build up
leverage for a few months,
and kinda work towards that?
- That's a strategy.
- [Corey] Okay.
- 'Cause if you come in hot on day one,
and telling the managers, what the fuck?
- [Corey] Yeah, that's not gonna work out.
- It sure isn't.
The number one mistake
in our society right now
is people are yelling at
each other on social media
trying to convince those people
to see the world the way that they see it.
- [Corey] Gotcha.
- Yeah, you just can't come
in with that level of audacity
that on your first day
you're gonna hot take.
By the way, good news.
David's live on Twitter.
- [Corey] Oh, nice.
- Does that make sense to you?
- [Corey] Yeah, I got your side.
I just need to like kinda calm down,
and keep my head down,
and figure things out,
and build up some leverage, and kinda--
- Or listen and pay
attention to the managers.
You might find somebody
that actually sees the world
the same way you do, and
you lean into that person.
- [Corey] Okay.
I got you.
- See where I'm going?
- [Corey] Yeah.
- I appreciate your demeanor,
because I'm glad you were listening,
because it makes sense when
I point it out to you, right?
- [Corey] Yeah, I guess that's kinda
been my conundrum for a long time.
I have a bunch of these ideas,
and I think it comes from
watching my dad try to do this,
and bang his head against the
wall for the last 15 years.
It's kinda made me wanna...
It kills me on the inside
when people go to work,
and they're passionate about what they do,
and they can't do it, and
I've seen that a few times.
- Bro, I got news for you.
This isn't the Soviet Union.
- Yeah.
- Somebody that goes to work,
and is upset with their manager
can go to another place.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- We need to get off of
some of this ideology.
- [Corey] I got ya.
- It's important, it's important.
This is an important conversation,
'cause you're a good kid.
I like what you're talking about,
but sometimes we go too far,
and if we don't stay in the
middle we're gonna lose.
Do you understand?
- [Corey] Yeah.
- Like it makes me sad
about a lot of things,
but people are in control.
- [Corey] You're right.
- People walk in my office,
and tell me all sorts of shit.
I'm like, life's about alternatives.
Like if this place is so fucked
up go work somewhere else.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- I was born in the Soviet Union,
where they told you where
the fuck you worked,
and if you didn't they
fucking shot you in the face.
This is fucking America.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- You don't like Dell
go work for Microsoft.
- [Corey] I got ya.
- So, what you do is you either...
But I love where you're coming from,
so either you stay quiet,
build leverage, get thoughtful,
or when you see somebody
who's also passionate
about putting players in
the positions to succeed
you get cozy up to them,
and let them be a mentor.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Corey] I have like one more question,
all right--
- Go ahead.
Go fast, go fast, go fast.
- [Corey] Is this
something where, should I,
'cause this is what I'm passionate about,
and I really like working
with other people.
- Are you going into HR?
- [Corey] I'm not going into HR.
I've never really seen myself in HR,
and I didn't know that's
something that HR kinda does.
- It is.
A good HR place does.
- [Corey] Okay, so you think
I should kinda like look
into HR if I have that kind of attitude,
and those kind of like aspirations?
- If you kind find some place like Vayner
where they put HR culture
and people on a pedestal,
and it's not about just juggling
around dollars, you know?
- [Corey] Yeah, well I'd be pretty stoked
to come work for you one day, but.
- You can email me right now, brother.
You can email me right now.
I mean we're building out our HR.
I like where your head's at.
- [Corey] Where at, 'cause I--
- Gary@vaynermedia.com.
Put in the title I was the
kid that called about HR.
You'll be on the phone with
Claude next fucking week.
- [Corey] I will do that.
Thank you.
It was Gary at what?
- Vayner media.
- [Corey] Gary@vaynermedia.com.
Okay, I will do that right now.
- See ya.
All right, this kid's on fucking live.
Let's go.
Get it loud, Andy.
Here we go, here we go.
- [David] I'm being dead serious man.
I was being dead serious.
Oh my god, dude.
- 700 people are watching.
- [David] Yep, I'm gonna go
ahead and buy a plane ticket.
I'm sorry I keep repeating it.
I'm just so happy right now.
- This is unbelievable.
We just changed this kids' life.
- [David] I'm gonna go ahead,
and buy a plane ticket.
I'm gonna go see what they got.
I'm already packed up.
Like I said I'm already
packed up, ready to go.
I have my Logic shirt.
Represent Logic.
Damn, man.
But anyway love y'all so much,
(Gary laughing)
- His audience.
- We'll keep in touch.
It's probably gonna be, what was it?
Probably like at about an hour, or so.
Maybe less hopefully.
I'm gonna go live again,
but everybody go follow me.
Tell your friends everything.
Yes, it is 100% true.
No, I cannot believe it,
but yes it is 100% true.
I love y'all, and I can't believe
this has happened to me right now,
and yes, I don't care what anyone says
I am believing when Gary
V says, I love y'all.
And yep, I'm doing my own thing now.
I'm doing my own thing.
It is motherfucking time.
- Yes, bro.
- [David] It's my motherfucking time.
- It is your motherfucking time.
- [Woman] There's people
already commenting,
I need a video guy in L.A.
- Just changing people's
fucking lives, right?
It's just so crazy.
This is so real.
Like it's such a special time.
Look what we just did.
Do you understand what's
happening in the world?
Everybody's looking for bad,
and this stuff is happening.
Every day versions of this is happening.
This kid was fucking...
Like do you understand like actually
what it means to change somebody's life?
(laugh) yeah, I mean it's like (laughs).
It's just so surreal.
It's just so fucking surreal.
Like if the Internet didn't come along
I would've built 8,000
fucking liquor stores.
Would've been fucking super successful.
Would've fucking sold
it, and bought the Jets.
Everybody would've thought I was the best,
and it wouldn't have been anywhere
close to as interesting of a life.
This kid was laying in his
fucked up mom's house in San Antonio,
and he's in a car right
now flying to Los Angeles,
and people are pinging him left and right
for him to be their video person.
The dude's gonna be living his dream.
He was making 10 bucks an hour.
He's gonna make 10, it
doesn't, 12, who gives a fuck?
Nine, whatever.
He's literally 48 hours.
Memorial Day.
In a week, everything he dreamed about
an hour before I went live on a day
that I didn't need to
come back here at all,
still fucking a little fucked
up from my crazy travel.
Fought for it.
This is how the world works.
Fought for it, right?
Like, you know?
Like took a stressful call outside.
Watched these three fucking
outside doing who knows what.
I was like smiling.
It made me happy.
(crew laughing)
And then got off that call.
Yeah.
You three were outside just now.
It was awesome.
I was like watching them
like, what are they doing?
It was fun.
I was like on this fucked up call,
then ran up here, and fucking went live,
and changed this fucking kid's life.
(crew laughing)
So awesome.
Andy, tell her about yours.
Andy, fucking...
Do you know how Andy got his job?
Same shit, just like this, right?
Then think about that Andy,
like we all change each other's lives.
It's so fun.
So how'd you get your job?
- [Andy] I don't know
how you found that email.
- I used to read every email.
- Wait.
You responded three months later.
- It took me time, dude.
I was getting a lot of email.
(crew laughing)
Do you know what question that is?
That's like the same question--
- You told me to email you.
I was like, fuck, I gotta
write the best email ASAP,
or he's never gonna respond.
You didn't respond in the first week,
and then I was like, that's it.
It's never gonna happen.
And the thing is three
months later at midnight.
- That, I love that.
- It was literally like 12:01 a.m.
I had the email.
- Nobody believes me about anything.
- [Woman] Hello, please state
your name after the tone
and Google Voice will try to connect you.
- How did you have money to fucking...
You say you made no money.
How'd you fucking have money
to invest in Twitter and Facebook?
I'm like, I fucking lived in
a shit apartment and saved money.
I made $43,000 a year, and saved $11,000.
Sinan fucking...
Sinon?
(crew laughing)
Sinan?
- [Man] Sinon, man.
- Sinon?
- Yeah.
- Sinon.
- [Man] You said, "Sinon."
- How do you say it?
- [Man] Sinon.
- [Woman] Sinon.
- How do you say it?
- I say C-non.
(crew laughing)
- Sinon fucking commuted from fucking
to Wine Library in a
liquor store for a year.
Worked from fucking minimum wage.
He wanted it.
Like I love when people,
some people here are like, oh you know.
Like they come in, they do
the residence thing whatever.
And after like you know you watch,
'cause some of you are still in it,
and others are like, and I watch right.
And some people are like
after week three or six.
Day one is cool.
Like fire, week three.
Sinon fucking commuted
from fucking to New Jersey,
and walked to Wine Library
for a year at minimum wage.
This is what is interesting.
It's one big game of entitlement
if your ambitions are big.
I'm always curious of like
what's the person's ambition.
It's not for everybody,
but like if you want it so.
But, you know, I don't know.
I'm fascinated by it, 'cause
I really ate fucking...
I did it, lived it.
You know it's so fun to
give advice you've lived.
Makes it fun.
Makes it fun, I never feel weird.
- [Woman] Hello, please state
your name after the tone
and Google Voice will try to connect you.
- I really did it.
(phone beeps)
Gary.
(line trilling)
Really did it, and then started this--
- [Jacqueline] Hello.
- Hello.
- [Jacqueline] Hi, Gary!
- Hello, How are you?
- [Jacqueline] I am awesome,
because you called me.
- Well, I guess I did Jacqueline.
(Jacqueline laughing)
- [Jacqueline] So, I own
a sugar cookie business
that I run out of my house.
I have four kids.
One of them has special needs,
and gets therapy all the time,
and so I do all of my
work when they're asleep.
My husband has a job, but we wanted me
to be able to stay home, but
I really like selling cookies.
It's a lot of fun.
Everybody loves cookies.
Who doesn't love cookies, right?
- I'm gonna buy so many of your cookies.
Your opening sentence, like.
Jacqueline, you have to understand.
Like I love you so much.
Like I'm literally right before
I called you talking about entitlement.
You're a mother of four,
building a business
when everybody goes to sleep.
You've a special needs child?
- Yeah.
- And people are yelling at me
like, eh, Gary V, like what the fuck?
Like how do I live in
Brooklyn at 14 bucks an hour?
Like move.
Live with a roommate.
Don't buy $4 Blue Bottle coffee.
- [Jacqueline] (laughs)
Entitlement I think
is the main problem.
- Your cookies are crazy.
You make these?
- [Jacqueline] Yeah, I made those.
And I won best tasting sugar
cookie in Houston, Gary.
- All right, ready for this?
Hold on, hold on.
- I'm ready.
- Hold on.
So it's Tudor House Cookies, right?
Okay, so right now.
- Yes.
- You have 3,696 followers.
3,696 followers.
- Yes.
- Everybody's watching right now.
If you've ever gotten anything from me
in any shape or form that's been good
I want you to go to Tudor House Cookies.
T-U-D-O-R House Cookies
- Hell yes.
- T-U-D-O-R House Cookies.
Tudor House Cookies.
They look ridiculous.
- Gary, I'm dancing
around my house right now.
This is freaking awesome.
- Are you drinking a Dr. Pepper?
- [Jacqueline] Not at the moment.
I did earlier.
- But you love Dr. Pepper?
- [Jacqueline] I do love Dr. Pepper.
It's so good.
Dr. Pepper is gonna be in heaven, Gary.
(crew laughing)
It's so good.
- Listen to me, and listen to me good.
Your cookies look insanely amazing.
- [Jacqueline] Thank
you, and they taste good.
I won best tasting
sugar cookie in Houston.
They look good, and they taste
good, 'cause I'm awesome.
- I see everybody else now following.
I don't know what fucking...
Unbelievable.
- [Jacqueline] Okay,
should ask my question.
- Good news.
You've picked up like 200 followers quick.
- [Jacqueline] Oh, I'm so excited.
Okay, so my question is I actually had
a meeting with a chick at
Aramark a couple of months ago
because she is like
head of sales and stuff
at Reliant Stadium,
which is the huge football stadium here.
- Hold on, we can't buy yet.
- I'm not allowed to ship,
because I don't have a commercial kitchen.
- What?
- [Jacqueline] So yeah, so
every state has different laws
about people that bake out of their house,
and Texas is stupid,
and you can't ship them
if you make them out of your house.
If you make them out
of a commercial kitchen
you can do whatever the hell you want.
- Okay.
- [Jacqueline] So that
makes it a lot harder
to get business, because
I can't just sell on...
Epsy or whatever.
- Hey Jack?
- [Jacqueline] Yeah?
- You're up to 4300 followers.
(Jacqueline laughing)
- [Jacqueline] Oh that's awesome.
- All right, so can't you fucking
rent a commercial kitchen
for like a day, and fucking bang them out?
- [Jacqueline] Well, you have
to get a million dollar insurance policy.
- And how much does that cost?
- [Jacqueline] A couple thousand dollars.
- I'll buy it for you.
- [Jacqueline] You don't have to do that.
But if you want to--
- No shit.
- [Jacqueline] That would be awesome.
(crew laughing)
Oh my god.
Okay, so this is my idea on how
I can stay home with my kids,
but also make a shit ton of money.
So, I met with her at Aramark.
I met with this chick, right?
- Okay.
- [Jacqueline] And she said,
"Would you ever be interested
"in doing live demos at
conventions like OGC?"
Which is in Houston every
year, and it's freaking huge.
- Keep going.
- And I said, absolutely.
- Yep.
- And she said,
okay, make up a price
sheet, and send it to me.
So I did some research.
I've never done anything like this before,
so I did some research
on what they normally pay
for decorated cookies, and
all that kind of stuff.
I sent her a price sheet.
She said, "They look good.
"I'll look at the details,
and get back to you."
She never got back to me.
I emailed her--
- Good.
She got busy.
I tell people to email me all the time.
I told the kid to email me about HR.
I might not reply.
I'm being dead serious.
What's that, Alex?
- [Alex] Yeah, it's true.
- Who said that.
- I didn't hear what you said.
What?
- We try.
I'm trying real hard out here.
It's not my intent at the moment,
but we're drinking out
of a fucking fire hose.
I don't want somebody
walking around earth saying,
Gary V told me to email him,
and then didn't email me.
It fucks up my brand.
I'm trying to answer every time,
but who the fuck knows?
Tyler fucking deletes it by accident.
Right, Ty?
It happens.
Alex, you've deleted
shit by accident, right?
- [Alex] Of course.
- 'Cause you're human.
I do shit wrong every minute.
So who gives a fuck that
she hasn't got back to you.
Hit her up 14 more times,
or if not fuck her.
- [Jacqueline] Well, so
I emailed her once a week
for the last three weeks,
and she didn't respond,
so I was like, "Okay, forget it."
But now--
- Good.
I like everything about you, Jack.
- [Jacqueline] (laughs) so now I want
to try and like hit up some other people
like maybe the lady that
runs all the food stuff
at like Georgia-run Convention Center,
which is five minutes from our house.
- Jack, why don't we
start a business together,
and I just get a kitchen in Texas,
and we just fucking dominate?
- [Jacqueline] Let's freaking do it, Gary.
- Okay.
- Let's do it.
- [Jacqueline] Yeah.
- I think what you're doing is,
I mean I assume other people
make good-looking sugar cookies.
These just look good, and I just like you
mainly because you posted,
I love Jesus, but I curse a little.
- [Jacqueline] Well, I do.
I mean I cursed on this call,
but I do also love Jesus,
so that's accurate (laughs).
- I really, really, really
like what you're doing.
I think you really have talent.
It's really, really, really good.
- [Jacqueline] Thank you so much, Gary.
That's awesome.
I told Andy. I tweeted
him about like 50 times.
Well, not really that much, but I told him
I was gonna send y'all
cookies, so I'm gonna send
y'all some cookies, because--
- Well, you better send us some cookies,
because I gave you like 3,000
followers in like 16 seconds.
Actually what did we start at, 3600?
You picked up a thousand
fucking followers already.
- [Jacqueline] That's freaking awesome.
- Jason doesn't even have
a thousand followers.
(crew laughing)
Do you?
- Oh my god.
- I have no idea (laughs).
I just thought it was funny.
(crew laughing)
All right, Jack, gary@vaynermedia.com.
Email me, let's see if we
can figure something out.
- [Jacqueline] Yes, definitely.
Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
This is fun.
Let's keep going.
- [Andy] There was another really good
cookie caller from before.
- The one from Florida?
Yeah.
- No, no, no.
- The 401 or like...
- It was like a year and a half ago.
- Okay, go ahead.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(crew chatting)
Sinon.
(crew laughing)
Is that right?
- No.
- It's not?
- [Woman] Sinon.
- Sinon?
(line trilling)
Sinon.
Non, it's the non part,
and I want to do nan.
I have this non-nan issue.
Sinon.
Your non, he's a non good guy.
That's how I'm gonna remember it.
I will literally call him Sinon.
Yo.
- [Caller] Hey.
- What's going on?
- [Caller] Who is this?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Caller] Oh, get the fuck out of here.
- Yeah, bro I got you.
How are you?
- [Caller] Holy shit, I'm doing well.
- Super well man.
What can I answer for you?
- [Caller] So I guess a little background.
I'm 27.
I work in real estate investments,
because I like apartment buildings,
and I'm just trying to
start like all the marketing
and branding for our company and stuff
and start doing it myself,
and I guess two part question.
One, should I focus on myself,
or do it through the company?
- Yourself.
- [Caller] And two, how
do I get bigger on YouTube
and Facebook because I'm struggling there?
- Yourself and slowly.
- [Caller] Okay.
- So, definitely focus on yourself,
and I wouldn't overly
worry about getting big
on YouTube and Facebook for
the sake of getting big.
What you need to focus on,
everybody focuses on
getting big; more followers.
They need to focus on making content
that brings value to people.
The reason I always win is I
only think about the customer.
I never think what's in it
for me ever, ever, ever.
I've never thought about
how many follower do I have.
How many followers am I gonna get?
Never ever, ever.
That's why I don't celebrate
when I get one million followers,
or 20,000 followers, or
whatever it is, right?
- [Caller] Mm-hmm.
So, I guess I didn't necessarily mean big.
I think partly I did, 'cause--
- Of course you did.
- [Caller] I still have that in my mind--
- Everybody, like, I understand it.
So, the answer is make content
that brings value to people.
- [Caller] Yeah, we're
starting to do that.
Like we host like MeetUp and stuff,
and we just posted a video
of like two hours long
on YouTube and we're gonna
start chopping it up,
and putting it on different stuff.
But I guess it's more like I understand,
because I work more and
do stuff on Instagram,
and a little bit on LinkedIn.
I kind of see the different subtleties
between the two of them.
- Yep.
- [Caller] Is there any
different subtleties
that you would change between going
towards Facebook and YouTube?
It is more wall form?
- Yes.
- [Caller] Is it a
different way of talking?
- Yes.
- How does that play out?
- Yep.
The answer is both.
You get more long foreign
options on both of them,
and the audiences are different.
You know Facebook is skewing
older by the second, right?
YouTube is super broad.
You could target ads on Facebook
in your general area and
an age group, so yeah.
- [Caller] Okay, cool.
Can I ask some more?
- You can ask one more quick question.
But real quick when I looked at your--
- [Andy] That's not him.
- Oh, that's not him, okay.
Keep going, bro.
- [Caller] Yeah, so the
next thing we wanna do
is start doing like
Facebook and Instagram ads,
and we obviously raise money
from the investor high
network accredited guys,
and we have to obviously,
there's some gray areas with FTC
and some stuff like that,
and we have to make sure we're
not stepping over boundaries.
What are some ways that you would get
people to your website without,
we can't say, hey, I've got
this investment opportunity.
We talked about doing like webinars--
- Yes.
- And stuff like that.
Is there anything besides the
kind of the norm that you see
that you recommend trying?
- Education and entertainment.
- [Caller] I heard of
that one before, yeah.
- It really works, bro.
I'll give you another one that
is a little more tangible.
You can send out an email,
a Tweet, an Instagram post.
You hit up everybody,
everybody, right that you have,
and you ask and spend one
day calling all of them,
and asking them for what
kind of content do they want.
- [Caller] Okay.
- Like one of the reason I'm
successful is I do research.
I read all my comments,
and I'm good at synthesizing
data to be a creative.
A lot of people never even get
into the part of even listening.
- [Caller] I hear ya.
I definitely try to do that.
I'm always asking people.
We literally just had
our meet-up last night
for like three hours.
- That's awesome.
- [Caller] In a hotel we had
like 40 people out there.
- That's good.
- [Caller] And I'm always asking people,
how did you like it?
What did you think?
Stuff like that and--
- But you gotta ask them what
do they want on your website,
or what do they want from your content.
- [Caller] Yeah, that's the thing too.
We always send out an email.
We always focus it
around one subject like,
"Oh, what do you guys
want to talk about next?"
And like we just did it on--
- Have you ever, you also
could use Google Trends,
and type in words from your industry,
and see if anything's popping.
- [Caller] So, I played
with that a little bit.
I've got like a running
quote unquote Google ad
just to like understand it a
little bit for the company.
- You know what it sounds like
the deficit is potentially right now?
Ideas.
- [Caller] So, yeah, I'm definitely,
I'm not like a marketing
background or design.
I'm trying to pick up the pieces as I go.
Just familiar enough to then
eventually outsource it either--
- I love it.
- [Caller] Like the next step I want to do
is have like a couple VA's start doing
post video production and stuff like that,
and then eventually bring on
someone full-time to do video,
and editing, 'cause it's
not my strong point.
It's taking up a fuck
ton of my time right now.
And it's really, really
a waste of my time,
because it's not my strength.
- Well, it's not a
waste, because I do like
the context building, but
I like that you're aware
that there's a passing of the baton.
You know what I mean?
- [Caller] Yeah--
- I think you might've learned
a lot of what you could do.
Believe it or not as this may sound;
it sounds like the
ideas part to your point
this is where somebody creative matters.
One of the things that took
me a long time to realize
in my team, and my agency
and then just kinda like.
Only over the last two years I'm like,
wait, a minute why this feels so easy
is 'cause I'm creative.
But that was not something
I really leaned into.
It was something I took for granted,
because I leaned in more
towards I'm a business man.
- [Caller] Right, and I think
that's why we're trying...
Like we're literally on the
cusp with starting our podcast,
and I want to start
leaning into other people
where we also wanna do
like with the meet-up stuff
off a round table type
thing where you bring
other people, and it's really good.
- Keep going.
Keep going.
I like where you're going.
- [Caller] Okay, cool man.
- You got the pieces.
All right, good luck, bro.
(phone beeping)
Is he live yet?
- No.
- This dude is literally...
Cool, right?
That's neat.
- [Woman] His best
friend is going with him.
- His best friend is going with him?
Leaving his wife?
- [Woman] I don't know.
(crew laughing)
- [Woman] I got my best
friend, and we're going.
(crew laughing)
(line trilling)
- [Louis] And good night.
This is Louis Santiago.
- Louis, this Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Louis] Ah, what's up Gary?
How you doing?
- Super well.
You?
- [Louis] Blessed, man, blessed.
- What can I help you with?
- [Louis] I moved over here to New York
from New Jersey, and got into sports.
Thank God, and managed to grind.
They told me from the
beginning, and I'm through it.
My biggest fear right
now is not to burnout.
You know what I mean?
I work more than 60 hours a week,
and that's just the way sports is.
You preach it.
You gotta work your ass off, but.
- You're worried?
- Yeah.
- What are you feeling?
- [Louis] I go back
home after a home game,
and I just come back home after a game,
and I'm just knocked out.
- Tired.
- [Louis] Yeah, I feel destroyed.
- Well, what do you want to happen?
You wanna balance it a little more?
- [Louis] A little bit,
but then I feel like
I wouldn't be able to get there.
I wouldn't be able to get to my next step.
- Life has cost, right?
- [Louis] Yeah, you're a 100% right.
- Are you physically
tired, or mentally tired.
- [Louis] I think it's more mentally,
since I'm usually not on the field.
Like I'm not really doing
anything physically.
- Yeah.
Are you feeling pressured from anybody;
significant other, parents, friends?
- [Louis] I mean just
your regular management.
That's just normal.
That's just sells and sports and--
- No, no, no.
Are you feeling pressure from anybody
in your life to be home more?
- [Louis] Not really.
Not yet at least.
I think that's more to come.
- Are you--
- Go ahead.
- Are you potentially being impatient?
- [Louis] How do you measure that?
- Well, I mean I think the
way you can measure this,
do you feel antsy like
I'm getting burnt-out,
and crap I'm not getting what I deserve.
Have you said, am I not getting recognized
the way I deserve,
or have any of those kinds of
things come into your mind?
- [Louis] A little bit.
Nothing crazy.
I try to block that off, but
I'm not gonna lie to you, yeah.
- That would be a sign.
How long you been there?
- [Louis] 'Bout to go for a year.
- Do you feel confident
that you are going to get recognized,
or at least if you put in these years
leverage to go to another ball club?
- [Louis] I think little by little
since there is more than 60 other people
within the sale's force, so I think
that will come it's just--
- Are you good at it?
- [Louis] My biggest fear.
Go ahead.
- Are you good at it?
- [Louis] I think I am.
I'm number two right now
in my own department.
Little by little moving up.
But at the end of the day
that's just my biggest fear
is like one of these days
I'm just gonna be like,
yo, this is too much, and walk out.
I've never done that before.
I'm straight outta college.
- What's the fear of that?
- [Louis] That's a good question
- Who gives a fuck if you do that?
You worried that your resume
is gonna say you were only
in a place for nine months,
and they're gonna ask?
- [Louis] That's a valid question.
- I know it's a good question.
That's why we're hanging.
- [Louis] Question for you,
do you ever get burned out?
- Not really, but it could happen.
Bro, you wanna hear something crazy?
Secretly, I would love to wake
up tomorrow, make a video,
be like, yo, I'm out, burned out, see ya.
Because it would help a lot of people.
- [Louis] Damn.
- Bro, when you don't care
about other people's opinions.
Like I just might go and buy
the Patriots on everybody.
- [Louis] Yeah.
- I'm kidding.
That won't happen.
But where I'm going with it
is like I don't fear to burnout.
I'm pretty self-aware.
I have been doing selling
and flipping since I was six.
There's a part of me that kind of feels
like this is some Tony Bennett shit.
You know what I mean?
Like 88 and shit with Gaga.
But if not, then not.
And what?
What's gonna happen?
People go on social media, and be like,
see, you all fucking looked up to Gary V.
He burnt out.
See?
You think I give a fuck what
JohnnyPants37 thinks about my burnout?
- [Louis] Damn, you're 100% right.
- I know, so you worrying about one day
you're just gonna wake up, and be like,
fuck this place, I'm out, for what?
So, good.
Reset.
It's the theme of tonight.
It's come up a second time.
Own your burn-out and move on.
Burning out's awesome.
What I mean by that is if we
stop calling it burning out,
and called it I changed my mind,
I think it would have less stigma.
- [Louis] Damn.
- Yeah I think we've made
it into this failure thing.
Burning out's awesome.
I've changed my fucking mind.
- [Louis] That's moving, man.
Damn.
- Good, man.
That makes me happy.
Like all of a sudden it's not scary.
Once it's not scary, it has no power.
- [Louis] Yeah.
- That's why I love bully shit, man.
Once the bully gets punched in the face.
(Louis laughing)
- [Louis] Damn, you're
changing life out here man.
- I'm trying, bro.
'Cause it's simple shit,
but sometimes you don't
see it from the angle,
and sometimes it takes
a random call at 9:44
on a Thursday night in late
May, and you hear something,
and it just changes the
way you walk in tomorrow.
- [Louis] Yeah.
More of I don't really care
about what might happen.
Just gotta roll with it.
- What's gonna happen is good.
Like what's gonna happen?
You know like...
You can get another
job, like I don't know.
Buy sports cards, bro.
- [Louis] All right, I like that.
- Have you been hearing
what I've been saying, man?
There's money to be made in
the next two years on cards.
- [Louis] Damn, that's
a leap, but fuck it.
Why not, right?
- I mean do you have $100?
- [Louis] Of course.
- I mean not of course, but like awesome.
Like you follow baseball?
- [Louis] Yeah, yeah, of course.
Yeah, you're right.
- Go buy some Bowman Rookie cards.
I'll give you a hot take right now.
This motherfucker right
here, Jordyn Adams.
He's a rookie, Jordyn Adams.
J-O-R-D-Y-N Adams.
- [Louis] Okay.
- I gave him love the other day.
Started talking to him.
He hit me up.
I'm talking to him on DM.
I like this kids game, man.
I think he's gonna be a real
player, and he's inexpensive.
You can buy Jordyn Adams cards.
Buy a bunch of them, flip them.
- [Louis] Interesting.
- They probably just went up.
- [Louis] I'll do my research.
- I like what you said my man.
That's a thoughtful answer.
Go do homework, bro.
I'm telling you right now
go on Ebay completed items.
Go look at baseball America's
Top 100 Prospect list.
Know what you know, do a side hustle.
There's a lot of people
about to make $100,000 a year
in profit flipping cards listening to me.
It's gonna happen.
Mark my words.
- [Louis] All right, when it
does to me I'll hit you up.
- What are you gonna say?
- [Louis] I'm gonna say I was the guy
that hit you up about getting burnt out.
(both laughing)
- Good luck, bro.
- [Louis] All right, man keep--
- Yo, sorry.
This burnout thing like what, like who?
Once you eliminate the judgment
of people around your failure.
I love when people try to
say shit about my failure.
I'm like, what about you?
You know, right?
Like seriously though, especially parents.
Especially siblings.
Nobody's remotely close to perfect.
- [Man] Do you think burnout's
related to impatience?
- It could be.
I think it's a really thoughtful question.
I do think burnout sometimes
is what people manifest impatience into,
and they think they're burnt out,
but what is was really was entitlement.
And it's actually them like
(imitating baby crying)
kicking, and screaming, you know?
But other times it's mental burnout.
There's a lot of people that burn.
And burnout, again, look I
think we have to be very careful
when we talk about these things.
There's people that have
mental health issues
versus people that put over-stress
on themselves versus mom situation.
He's got a mom situation,
and now he's on a plane.
So, when I talk about these things
I don't have all the context.
I don't want anybody to ever think...
That Paulo kid was taking
some of my stuff very blindly.
I'm worried about that stuff,
but yeah, man that dude is not burnt out.
That dude is just worried
about the ramifications
if he doesn't like his job.
Quit.
Nobody's looking at your fucking resume.
They don't give a fuck if you've
worked somewhere for three months.
Blame it on a crazy boss.
People do anyway.
I fired a fuck load of people
that suck shit then blame it on me.
(line trilling)
It's a fun night.
I like the random calling.
I feel better about--
(ringing drowns out Gary)
I like it also with like the last couple
of times I had to sell empathy, you know?
Just like--
(ringing drowns out Gary)
Fucking buying people million
dollar insurance and shit.
(crew laughing)
- [Woman] Please leave your message
for 772-418-6858.
(phone beeps)
- Aubrey, you fucked up.
(line trilling)
Hello?
- [Amir] Hello?
- Hello?
- Who's this?
- [Amir] Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Amir] I'm doing good, thanks.
How are you?
- I'm very well.
Who's this?
- [Amir] My name's Amir.
I'm the kid from Melbourne.
- Amir, it's great to see you.
- [Amir] Oh no.
I give you a random call
'cause I saw you in the Live,
and then I was like no
one (speaks quietly),
like press the number and
tried to call, you know?
- Yeah I love it.
- [Amir] And it works.
It worked, man.
How are you?
- Things are super well.
What can I help you with?
Tyler called him once from this number.
- [Amir] Quick question.
- Yes?
- [Amir] Basically, life is
really hard at the moment.
- Yep.
- [Amir] I made a fair bit of money,
and I wanna apply my knowledge
to help other people sell their cars.
- Okay.
- [Amir] The owner
secured a business name.
- Okay.
- [Amir] Sorry, I'm really nervous here.
- Don't worry.
- What's it called?
- I got good news.
I got good news, it doesn't
matter what it's called.
- [Amir] Yeah?
- Do you know why I'm saying that?
- [Amir] Because it's the product,
so it doesn't really matter
what the name is, right?
- Names are made.
Names are made, bro.
Names are made.
It doesn't matter what your name is.
Madonna means nothing until
she goes and executes.
Google means nothing
until it becomes Google.
Names are fucking made.
- Yeah.
- People spend 16 years coming up
with a fucking name for their business,
and zero days building
their fucking business.
- [Amir] That's good, I think.
Yeah, it took me awhile to
come up with mine, but--
- And that's okay.
I'm not judging people enjoying
the process of coming up with a name,
but the reality is it doesn't matter.
- [Amir] Yeah, yeah.
- Soccer box.
- [Amir] My question is so how can I--
- Yep.
- [Amir] 'Cause I'm only
16, right, I'm just a kid.
- Yep.
- [Amir] So how can
people take me serious?
- You can't convince people.
Listen as somebody, who lived it.
You can't convince people
to take you serious.
You just focus on the people
that took you serious.
That was fucking smart, man.
- Yeah.
- That's such good shit.
No, that's smart shit, right?
You're not gonna convince somebody,
who thinks a 16-year-old,
what are you gonna say?
I'm older than you think?
- Exactly.
(laughs) I wish I was older, but.
- No, you don't.
You think you wish you were older.
When you're older you're gonna
wish you were younger, bro.
I wish I was 16.
I would rip my fucking arms
off to be 16 right now.
- [Amir] (laughs) I wish I was 18.
All I want to do is be 18.
I think about so many things
like I took a year off school,
because of the internship thing,
and it didn't quite work
out, because of my age again.
- Ask Tyler if he's good.
- [Amir] I'll have to go back to school,
because obviously my
parents want me to do it.
And I'd say within that six
months out here with school
I've been flipping cars.
I've been researching about detailing cars
and how to help people sell their cars.
I'm getting so many
knowledge and all this stuff.
And now I'm trying to build my business
from the ground up, you know?
- I love that.
- [Amir] And I'm hyped, man, 'cause...
And at the moment the only person
that believed in me is
myself, and that's all I need.
I don't need anyone else, but myself.
- Biggest facts of the night, bro.
Listen, stay patient.
Stay patient.
That's the only thing I would tell you.
- [Amir] Yeah, 100%.
- Dude, I've almost lived
three of your lives.
- [Amir] Yeah (laughs).
Exactly, exactly.
- Awesome.
- All right, Gary.
- All right, talk to you.
Thank you, mate.
16.
Annie?
Tyler, anything good there?
No, right?
Give me one more soccer box.
(crew chatting)
- The other one, bro.
- It's hard to pull right?
- [Man] It's all (speaks quietly)
- What's the best card in the set?
- [Man] It's probably
(speaks quietly) Zack Santro.
- Who?
- [Man] Zack Santro.
- Santro?
- Santro, (speaks quietly).
- He's legit?
So Santro live, like signed?
(line trilling)
Santro?
- [Man] Is it on?
(line trilling)
- [Caller] Hello.
- Hello.
- [Caller] Hi.
- Hi, this Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Caller] Hey, what's up Gary?
- Life is good, bro.
How are you?
- [Caller] I'm doing swell.
Thanks for asking.
- What can I help you with?
- [Caller] My man, I actually just
started a new job recently.
A family company, they own a steak house
and a couple of places off Birmingham.
And I was looking at Empathy Wines.
I want to get in touch
with a wine director,
and try to get some
Empathy into my store, so--
- That's very sweet.
- [Caller] I couldn't
find out on the website,
so maybe you could help me with that.
- Yeah, email me at gary@empathywines.com,
and I'll help you.
We're about to open up
on-premise opportunities.
We've done a little social outreach,
and I would love your help.
Thank you.
- [Caller] Yeah, thanks Gary.
- Anything I can answer for you?
- [Caller] Actually, you know what,
I work with a couple of mentors right now
that's in this space.
I'm working with Jordan and
Mike right now on their--
- That's awesome.
- [Caller] Yeah, so they're
really helping me right now.
I follow all your content.
Putting all of your stuff into practice.
- Thank you, bro.
- [Caller] I'm really
working on finding the time.
- Did they tell you all their
success is attributable to me?
(crew laughing)
- [Caller] They gave 110%
credit to you, my man.
- I appreciate it.
- I actually just saw Jordan's
YouTube video about you so that was great.
- Awesome, bro.
Thank you so much for calling.
- [Caller] Hey, Gary.
Love you, man, thank you.
- Love you back.
(line trilling)
Thank you.
- [Woman] Welcome.
(muffled speaking)
- They're really good.
(line trilling)
- [Aubrey] Hello.
- [Man] Aubrey.
- Aubrey.
- [Aubrey] Gary!
- What up, bro?
- [Aubrey] Yo, everything is up right now.
Oh my god.
I can't believe you just called me, bro.
- I had to.
- [Aubrey] Yo, what is going on, bro?
I just messaged DRock.
I've been watching you
for like three years, bro.
- I appreciate it.
- [Aubrey] Like you are literally like
the big brother/father I never had, bro.
- Humbled, thank you for that.
- [Aubrey] It's crazy, bro.
It's crazy like...
I guess I got so many
question I could ask you, man.
But the most important question is like
I've done businesses online.
I've made money online.
Like I see you preach Facebook ads,
and I see you preach not to give a fuck
about what anybody thinks,
and I definitely don't,
so I guess the main thing
is like just people--
- But while I've got you...
- What was that?
- while I've got you,
I'm gonna use this as an opportunity.
Not giving a fuck about
what anybody thinks
means don't allow anybody's judgment
to disproportionately penetrate your own,
but respecting other people's feedback,
and being thoughtful about
it is incredibly important,
so I don't give a fuck
about what anybody thinks,
yet I interact with
people that are trolling,
and negative to me, because
I like understanding
people's points of view, and
I have that humility as well.
So it's not just being so confident
that you don't give a fuck.
It's also equally being humble enough
to be thoughtful about
hearing the feedback,
but it's important to understand
how to balance those two.
- [Aubrey] Right, I
understand that completely.
I guess I just worded it wrong,
because I'm freaking nervous.
- No no, no no.
You're wording it right.
I'm saying it that way,
and I'm taking advantage
of this moment to clarify.
- [Aubrey] Got you, got you.
Yeah, so I mean I guess
the main thing is...
This is gonna sound very
Kanye and arrogant-like.
- Okay.
- But at the end of the day
you really remind me of myself.
- Okay.
- [Aubrey] Because honestly,
bro I'm just being real,
and like I have a single mom, right?
- Yep.
- And it's just me.
And it's me and the dog, and my family.
And I take care of my mom, my grandma.
And it's just me, bro.
So like I said, fuck school.
And I just wanted to go all in.
I've been selling shoes
and like flipping stuff.
Like going out to like sneaker releases
four o'clock in the morning.
Like all this shit that
you preach I've done that,
and you just like confirmed it.
Like seeing you document all this stuff,
you just confirmed it, bro.
My mom is like my biggest motivator, bro.
Like she put me onto
the garage sale stuff,
and then when I found
out about you doing it
like that just made it like
wow this is actually real.
So, like I guess the
thing is what could I do
to like get back on my grind to how I was?
Because I was making
a couple hundred bucks
without even having to go into a job.
- So what the fuck happened?
- [Aubrey] I feel like
I just lost that drive.
- Why?
- [Aubrey] I don't know
what's stopping me, bro.
- Did you get soft?
- [Aubrey] No, it like literally--
- Did you care what
somebody thought about it?
- [Aubrey] Yeah, well--
- That's good.
That's fine.
- [Aubrey] I mean--
- Listen, I know it took
everything I had in high school
once all the pretty
girls in my high school
that were friends with me
found out I garage saled,
it took every ounce of
my uber self-confidence
to persevere and I barely persevered,
so I know the average
person struggles with this,
but I still did it.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, I understand.
And I think the main
thing that's stopping me
'cause I've even sold cars.
I bought and flipped cars, and sold those.
- That's fine, so what's the prob?
What's the prob?
- [Aubrey] It's just like--
- Tell me the truth.
Who made you stop?
It's okay.
You're a kid.
Who made you stop?
- [Aubrey] I mean I'm 27-years-old now.
- You're a kid.
Who made you stop?
- [Aubrey] Well, I was dating this girl
at this one time, and it
kinda fucked up everything
just because of like I
guess I was distracted,
because of what her family
thought about me at the time too.
- The end.
The end.
- [Aubrey] No, that was canceled in 2017.
- No, no, the end.
That's what started the process.
- [Aubrey] What do you mean?
- It sounds like the reason you stopped,
losing your way was you were worried about
the outside judgment of
your girlfriend's family,
and that's what started
you getting off that grind.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and it's kinda gotten
a little bit bigger than that,
because it was like from a small hometown,
and everybody kinda knows each other,
and I was like I know you preach about
like micro-influencers, and like when
you handle a certain point of like people
starting to notice you,
some people take it to their head,
and I fucking took it to the head.
- Okay, so you got gassed up,
because people thought--
- [Aubrey] I got super fucking gassed up,
because I actually met a
lot of different rappers,
and I did like marketing.
I worked for free for a
lot of artists like K CAMP.
- Yep.
- Sire and Kidd.
- [Aubrey] A lot of different
Atlanta music artist.
- Yep.
- [Aubrey] I worked for
free for like two years.
- Okay.
- [Aubrey] Just because
that was my main passion.
- I get it, and?
- [Aubrey] A lot of people
judged me from that point,
because like I always knew it
was different than just working a job.
- What do they judge you for?
Saying you're getting suckered?
- [Aubrey] Well, just because like
I don't really see school like
the only way to make money.
- That's fine.
So one more time what happened?
Her parents judged you, and said,
you should go to college
and get a real job?
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and
I ended up doing that,
and I went to--
- Yo.
Yo, my man, you remember when
you said you were like me?
- [Aubrey] Yeah.
- You're not, but that's
okay, 'cause I'm not special.
We're just different and
you need to understand that.
- [Aubrey] Yes, sir.
- And here's the good news.
You're 27.
- [Aubrey] I got time, right?
- Man, in a way that you can't imagine,
and every second that
you spend on yesterday,
and how you got fucked up and gassed up
and listening to parents is every second
that you're not spending about tomorrow.
- [Aubrey] It kind of
went to my peer groups,
and it didn't just go to parents.
It kinda went to my peer groups,
and now it's like even...
I hang around a lot of people,
and like we really grew, and
got really big in our hometown.
And a lot of people
started to know my name,
and like we do business
online, and things like that--
- My man you got gassed up
in a small little shit spot in Atlanta.
I'm fucking blowing up in the
world, and I'm not gassed up.
We're different.
- [Aubrey] Yo, I actually got gassed up
in Port St. Lucie, Florida.
- I don't give a fuck.
- I drove--
- What the fuck is Port
St. Lucie fucking Florida?
- [Aubrey] This middle of
no where shit hole town.
- Hold on, be careful now.
(crew laughing)
- [Aubrey] It's seriously in
the middle of no where man.
- So why did you fucking think
that you were so fucking great
when you were dominating Port St. Lucie
where I think the fucking
Mets played spring training?
- [Aubrey] Because I started here,
and I worked my way up.
I guess I just went backwards,
and all over the place.
I don't know, man.
It's just crazy that I'm
even on the phone with you.
It was just like I actually
went from Port St. Lucie
to Tallahassee and went to school,
and then I drove from Tallahassee
in my car to Atlanta, Georgia.
- Is this you?
- I slept in my car
multiple nights just to go to video shoots
the next day with like
no money in my pocket
just to get back to my apartment,
and go to school the next week.
- Okay.
- And stuff like that.
- [Aubrey] So it's like I was
always just chasing a dream,
and not getting paid for it,
but at the end of the day
people didn't think
how I thought about it.
They were just like just go to school.
- And?
- Get a job,
and like now I'm back
in south Florida back and forth.
I'm not back in my hometown,
but I'm back and forth,
and it's like I don't know
how to get back to that grind.
Like what I have to do to start
grabbing those shoes and
flipping those cars again
because I sold like 24
cars in three years, right?
And that was just me
flipping them on Craigslist;
flipping them on OfferUp.
That was just me.
I would buy the car cheap as fuck,
and fix it myself, and that was hard.
- You remember the
question I asked you first?
Did you get soft?
- [Aubrey] Right.
- That's the answer.
- [Aubrey] I did.
- I know.
- No shit.
- [Aubrey] Damn.
Damn.
- Yeah, man.
Dude, the only reason--
- [Aubrey] Bro, I'm getting
goosebumps right now, bro.
- I get it, bro.
Listen, I understand.
Like you know it might
not resonate for John,
'cause he's making a face,
but for you it's real,
because you actually
just realized something.
Like I get it.
The single thing that
people don't understand
is I've been doing the same fucking shit.
I'm doing exactly what I did...
The amount of logic that
goes into me coming back
from where I just was
to this office tonight
after I just took the
fucking trip that I did.
I'm fucking exhausted.
Like truly exhausted.
Like this was such a strategically
smart move to go home early tonight.
But I'm like you know Memorial
Day's coming, so I got that.
What, did Alex say something?
Like why--
- I think he just laughed.
- Got it.
Like it just, right?
I'm still doing it, dude.
It's 10:00 p.m., I'm still doing it.
- [Aubrey] That's crazy.
That's crazy.
- Like I'm still doing it,
and by everybody's standards I made it.
You know what I could've done tonight?
Do you know what I could've done tonight?
- [Aubrey] You could've
done a lot of things.
Like feed the world.
- Anything I want.
Anything I wanted.
- Which is really hard.
- I could be doing anything I wanted.
- [Aubrey] That's what's so crazy, bro.
And what's got me like.
Bro, I swear two nights
ago I was on YouTube.
Bro, I watch your stuff
like it's my religion.
You know what I'm saying?
Like how you say I watch your stuff, bro--
- Watch half as much, and go
fucking sell something from Craigslist.
- [Aubrey] Yeah.
- Yeah, bro, people use me to feel
like they're doing something,
instead of doing something,
- [Aubrey] But at the same time like,
it was a different level, man.
Because I watched your interview,
and the thing that you
did with Nipsey, bro.
And like that right there to see a man
that was living, bro,
and that influential,
and to have a conversation with you,
I would have asked you
the same type of things,
and just to hear you and
him go back and forth, bro,
that was a dude that was
just here last month, bro.
Like just last month,
and like just the thing
how he picked up that
dude at the coffee shop,
and like those kinds of things.
Those moments, bro like people don't think
those kinds of things are real, bro.
But like it just can.
I left everything, and even
when I didn't have money
in school I went up there to start doing
the marketing campaigns,
and doing the South by
SouthWest Music Festival
with these artists and stuff.
And I wasn't getting paid shit.
I wasn't getting paid anything.
But people were like oh Aubrey
this guy he's just around,
and he's just around and
he's not doing anything.
- Aubrey, Aubrey, Aubrey.
- [Aubrey] That was my dream.
- Aubrey, you're living based
on other people's judgment.
- [Aubrey] I know.
It fucking sucks.
- No shit, it sucks, bro.
Why do you think I'm spending
my fucking life trying
to make content to get
people to stop doing it?
- [Aubrey] That's crazy.
- Aubrey, I rang up my friends
in my liquor store when I was 20.
How old are you?
You're 20 how?
- 27.
I turn 28 in December.
I'm almost 30.
- 30's young as shit, bro.
The fuck's the matter with you?
I'm 40 fucking three.
I'm cooler than you.
- [Aubrey] Man, it's just the pressure.
The pressure is like--
- From who?
- [Aubrey] My mom supports my dreams,
and everything--
- Stop.
What do you mean supports?
Emotionally, or financially?
- [Aubrey] No, wait.
Emotionally.
- So, good.
- [Aubrey] I wish she supported
financially, but like--
- No, you don't.
- [Aubrey] She's really all in like--
You don't want her to
support it financially.
Get back on your grind, bro.
- [Aubrey] I mean but the thing is
I could easily get back on my,
it's not that fucking easy
just to get on my grind.
- Why?
- [Aubrey] Like if I wanted to flip a car
it's just the initial getting capital
to do things like that.
like let's say for example
if I wanted to get--
- Bro, how much money
do you have, right now?
Negative how much?
- [Aubrey] Like just honestly--
- Yes.
What are we doing here?
Are we fucking trying
to do something good,
or are we gonna fucking bullshit
each other for the rest--
- [Aubrey] I mean...
- Rest of our lives?
- [Aubrey] I mean I just
paid my rent and my car, bro.
And like right now I'm just hustling.
- Bro, I'm not gonna judge you.
I'm asking you a basic question,
'cause I'm gonna help you.
I don't give a fuck if
you say negative 180,000.
- [Aubrey] Bro.
- Do you know how many
people are in the negative?
- [Aubrey] Oh my god, bro.
Bro, I got like to be real, bro.
- Real.
- I got like...
Bro.
- Bro, say it.
- I got like.
I got like $43 in my wallet.
Bro.
- Well, good news.
I know what do with $43.
(phone beeps)
- [Aubrey] What do I gotta do?
- You fucking know, bro.
Go to a fucking thrift store tomorrow,
and turn 43 into 200.
You know what to do.
- [Aubrey] I mean it's not like
I don't have money coming in either, bro.
'Cause like I have stuff that's
listed on Ebay right now,
and OfferUp.
- Bro, I'm not judging.
I'm telling you to go on the offense.
- [Aubrey] Okay, but I
mean like I have stuff
that's posted, and like
what gets me fucked up
is like all these kids, and stuff like
back when I was reselling
shoes it wasn't like that.
Like bro you go into a
line, and you either go
into a line with your boy,
give him an extra ticket.
Comp him a ticket to stand in line,
and hopefully you get four pairs each,
but now dudes are online, and
they're like 13-years-old,
and they're buying massive
amounts of quality shoes,
and like I'm feeling like that's
the only way to make a profit.
- And?
And?
- [Aubrey] And that's what I
know best is flipping shoes.
- Fucking learn something else.
Flip sports cars.
- [Aubrey] You're right.
- I know I'm right.
You're crying about yesterday.
You sound like you're 72.
In my day.
It changed.
Go fucking figure out how
to write an algorithm then.
Like what?
- [Aubrey] Yeah.
- Yeah, bro, you gotta
change your mindset, bro.
- [Aubrey] I gotta change my mindset?
- You gotta change your mindset, man.
You're looking backwards and defense,
and why not, instead of why yes.
- [Aubrey] And that fucked my up, man.
Because it really messed me
up for a couple of years.
- Good.
Good news, you're young as fuck.
Let's unmess you up, and
stop looking backwards.
Fine.
We had two, three years that sucked.
Cool.
Great.
Now, when you fucking taste beauty at 33,
you'll be grateful, even more so,
because you knew how
fucking shitty 25 to 27 was.
- [Aubrey] Right, and I mean, man,
I'm not asking for anything.
- Good.
- [Aubrey] I'm not asking
for anything at all,
'cause I got money now,
and I tell everybody,
"If I'm not good today,
I'll be good the next day."
So when everybody ask me--
- Bro.
- What I'm doing--
- You're living...
Bro, stop talking about everybody.
Dude, you are so in it for
everybody else's opinion.
When you go watch this
on YouTube or Facebook;
all you're talking about is
everybody else's opinions.
I'm not telling anybody anything.
I never told anybody anything.
What do you mean?
I'm not worried about what anybody thinks.
If I've got it now, if
I don't have it now.
If I use to have it now,
and I did have it now,
and I'm gonna have it now,
and I'm not gonna have it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So what?
- That's what I'm saying.
- Dude, I don't know what you're saying.
Every time you're answering
is you're living your life
based on other people's opinions,
because that's become your new framework.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and that
shit burns me out, bro.
- No shit.
That is the the problem.
- [Aubrey] For the past three years
it's burnt me out.
- Good.
So, let's not do it anymore.
- [Aubrey] '15, '16.
- So, let's not do it anymore.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, yeah, I
see what you're saying.
- Do you?
- [Aubrey] I mean, kind of.
It's just like the time
thing is how you say,
you've got time and everything.
It's like I want to pick
right back off where I was.
- You can't.
You fucked up.
- [Aubrey] Oh my god.
That's what I needed to hear.
- Good.
- [Aubrey] So you're
saying I should totally
switch up everything, and
just find something new?
- Probably, 'cause you're
super fucking salty and upset,
and fucked up right this second.
- [Aubrey] I got it.
- Bro, just 'cause you were great
at flipping five years ago.
Shit changed.
- [Aubrey] It has.
It really has.
- I'm sorry, and that's
what happens to everybody.
Guess what?
Kobe said he's not playing
basketball right now.
- [Aubrey] Damn.
- It changed, you're dwelling.
You're a fucking dwelling machine.
- [Aubrey] Wow.
- If I just didn't meet that girl
I would have stayed the course.
You're living for yesterday.
My sister should be sitting here.
The second she decided
to live for tomorrow
after 40 fucking years, she got happy.
But she spent her whole fucking life
worried about yesterday.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, I get it.
- You know how it works both ways?
- [Aubrey] How?
- It's how I'm humble and grounded.
This is how we're different.
We're actually reversed, bro.
We're reversed, because I don't
give a fuck about yesterday
meaning everything I've done good,
everything I've done.
I'm only as good as tomorrow.
It doesn't matter what I've done.
If I make 37 bad mistakes in a row
over the next two years then I suck.
- [Aubrey] And yeah, I was just watching
that video the other day.
You said like, say, if
I wanted to do something
for the next two years,
and I split it up six months each
like for the next two years
I could try something four times.
- Bro, you know how to sell.
You've won.
God gifted you.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, I really could sell
a snowball to Santa Clause.
- Well, right now you're
fucked up if you believe that,
'cause you have $43.
- [Aubrey] But I mean like the
next day I'll have some more.
- But 43's not a great fucking base,
so what I'm saying is as
somebody who knows how to sell
you gotta realize your shit's fucked up.
And it's fucked up because
you're looking backwards,
and you're saying, but it used to,
and they don't get it, and da
da da da da, you're dwelling.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and I also
bought a brand new 2017 Lexus,
and that kinda fucked me up.
- Of course if fucked you up, because--
- [Aubrey] Because I was worried
about everybody else's opinion.
- Of course you were.
As soon as you were
snowballing and losing money
you went all in on the other way.
- [Aubrey] All in.
- All in.
- I went all in.
- As soon as you knew
you were fucking uh-oh,
you're like now let me over
correct to fucking create
a disguise to how fucked up it's going.
- [Aubrey] Seriously, and
that's the point where I am now.
- Good.
- [Aubrey] Right now.
- Good, so now we're gonna reverse it.
- [Aubrey] Wow, that's what I need to do.
And that's what I'm trying
to is reverse it, exactly.
- Can I give you a real,
real, real, real, real
good piece of advice?
- [Aubrey] I'm here
writing this stuff down.
- Good, write this down.
Go talk to 10 people closest to you,
and tell them all the
truths of how fucked up,
and how unhappy you are
and see how they react.
- [Aubrey] So you want me
to go and tell the closest
people I know like all this shit?
- I want you to tell every
girl that you're looking at,
every best homie that
you've been coming up with,
and tell them you fucking
suck, and you got nothing.
You got $43, and fucking
Lexus with a fucking--
- [Aubrey] Oh, no that's gone.
- Good.
- That's gone.
- I was able to flip that.
- Good.
Bro, you need to fucking audit
who you're hanging out with.
- [Aubrey] I did, and I
chopped them all off, bro.
And now it's only me.
That's what I'm saying.
- Let's go.
- [Aubrey] I chopped them all off.
- So, we're ready.
- [Aubrey] And like I'm at that point
now to reverse it.
- Good.
Ready?
There's only one person
you gotta chop off left.
The 2005 to this second version of you.
The '15, excuse me.
The 2015 to today's version of you,
that's the last person you gotta cut off.
- [Aubrey] And just start something new?
- Around the thing your best at.
- [Aubrey] And this is
like one more thing, man.
There's like one more thing like,
you know how you saying
I gotta reverse it?
I'm getting caught up,
because a lot of people the
way that I was moving back then
of course, 'cause now you
know, I was just worried
about people's opinions really back then.
- Of course.
- And like I went all in,
and spent a whole bunch of money.
Like too much.
I did stupid things for
other people's judgment.
But in times like where I am now
I don't really care
about what people think
in the sense that if
they think I'm negative,
or if they think that I'm like--
- Of course you're there now.
You've got no choice.
They fucking left once you
didn't have the money, bro.
You live for other people.
Of course you're there now.
- Yeah.
- You have no choice.
If you had a choice you'd
still be there, bro.
- [Aubrey] All those people
still think I'm like.
Like you're saying to reverse it.
Like all those people, even
though I am where I am now;
I'm not where I was back then,
but if I were to go to those
people, those 10 people,
if I were to go to them,
like they're not even around.
Like I cut them off,
because it's the way that
I was moving back then.
I was moving off of jealousy,
and I was moving off of like trying
to like flex my local people,
and nowadays I don't care
about none of that stuff.
Like I flipped that Lexus.
I got rid of that.
I got a shitty apartment.
Like I'm living within
my means for real now.
- But you also just told me 12 minutes ago
that you're not going hard,
so you've done some parts right, but--
- [Aubrey] I'm not going hard.
- So why?
'Cause you're still depressed
from the L that you took?
- [Aubrey] No, I'm not
going as hard as I was,
because of those people.
Like all those that if I were to go,
and tell them like how fucked up it is now
like all those people like.
They won't hear me like
that, because I really--
- Bro.
- I really messed up.
(laughs) Bro, you're
living for other people.
Bro, let me give you some real good news.
Those 10 people, nobody
gives a fuck about.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, you're right.
- I know I'm right.
Those 10 people you put on a pedestal
don't mean jack shit just like
everybody navigating through high school.
For the coolest kids, who don't mean dick.
- [Aubrey] And all these
people on Facebook.
- Bro, you're still living for those
10 people, just so you know.
It just came out of your mouth.
Wait 'til you watch the rewind of this.
It's some dumb shit.
- [Aubrey] And I have a business online.
I have over 800 people in my organization,
and I mean we all are a team--
- Bro, you have $43.
- And like I'm trying
to build a community.
It's just hard.
- No shit, it's hard.
It's hard when you fucking live
your life for other people,
which is why I'm really
trying to get people
to not live their life for other people.
I'm on the phone with you
for 20 fucking four minutes.
I don't think I've spent 24 minutes
with Team Gary V this year.
It's the fucking truth.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, man,
I really just wanna do
like what you're doing one day,
and I mean not what you're doing exactly.
- No, listen to me.
You can do what I'm doing tomorrow.
- I just wanna make--
- Listen, to me.
- [Aubrey] Like positive
light onto people.
- Well, you're not gonna do that
if you're the most insecure
fucker on earth worried
about 10 fucking people
from Pensacola, Florida.
- [Aubrey] Because they
don't see me like that.
- I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna go--
(cross talking)
Bro, you are so fucked
with these 10 people,
I fucking hate these 10 people.
The fuck's a matter with you?
I don't give a fuck how
you're seen by them,
or how they see you, or
how they don't hear you.
You're so sucked in to
the bullshit of yesterday,
and these 10 people.
It's over.
Get the fuck over it.
You cut 'em off, because you took the L.
You had no choice.
You didn't cut them off emotionally.
- [Aubrey] No, I didn't.
It's like a little bit of
that saying got to my head,
and I started making a
little bit of money online--
- Bro, you didn't have fame.
You didn't have money.
- [Aubrey] I didn't but what I had
was a little bit of people
and that shit got to my head,
and like in my--
- Get it out.
Get it, yeah.
- Hometown.
I was just like being
an arrogant ass, bro.
And like now look where I am.
- Good, go apologize.
Deploy some humility.
Stop being a dick face.
- [Aubrey] And that's
what I've been doing.
That's what I've been doing though.
And that's what I'm saying.
That's where I am now.
That was in 2015.
- Okay.
- [Aubrey] Like I've been on
that gratitude is the movement
like all that stuff that
you preach, I'm on that.
And I've been on that
since September last year.
And it's just like now at
this point to where I am
it's like I'm on the internet,
and when I try and spread
like a positive message, fuck,
it's still that evil like--
- Because you haven't made the video yet
that calls yourself out.
- [Aubrey] I didn't, no.
I did not.
- That's why, bro.
The reason you're fucking
fucked is you're trying--
- [Aubrey] They still
think I'm that evil guy.
- So fucking make the video,
and tell everybody that
you were a fucking evil guy
from 2015 to 2017,
and it fucking brought
you to your fucking knees,
'cause you were a fuck
face, and you deserved it.
- It did.
- Now you're fucking changing,
and you're grateful that
it took you to your knees,
and you're excited for a new day.
And anybody that comes in--
- I swear.
- And talks about 2014 to
'17, I'm fucking sorry,
'cause I was a piece of shit,
but now I don't wanna be, and I'm sorry.
And I can't wait to look you in the face,
and I'm sorry.
But you haven't done that yet,
'cause you're not at the fucking place.
- I haven't.
- I know you haven't.
- [Aubrey] And I thought about just like
going on my Facebook, and
like recording a video,
and just like tagging my friends.
- Do it.
- And like everybody--
- Who reached out to me.
- Do it right now.
Hang up, make a video,
and say you were a fucking
fuckin' piece of shit
for five years and you fucked
up, and you lost your way,
and you were insecure,
and you were broken.
And you fucking have
been taken to your knees,
and I'm never going back their again.
And I'm gonna start all over,
and I'm gonna build, and that's what's up.
And if I see you in the streets,
or in the club, or somewhere,
I'm gonna apologize to your fucking face,
'cause I was a big
fucking dick for a decade,
or a half a decade.
- [Aubrey] And I thought
about doing that, so.
- But you haven't, because you're scared.
Because you're soft.
- [Aubrey] That's what I need to do.
- No shit.
Put your poison out.
The number one fucking
thing that most people,
who are watching this right now have to do
is fucking share their poison
'cause the second they
share it, they take control.
Right now the poison's got you.
- [Aubrey] It's got me, bro.
It's got me, and I don't want that.
I want to help people.
- So make--
- [Aubrey] And I don't
care about the money, bro.
- Aubrey, what's your fucking last name?
- [Aubrey] Medina.
- What's that?
- Good.
Hey internet.
- M-E-D-I-N-A.
- Aubrey Medina's a piece of shit
from 2014 to 2018, spread it.
- [Aubrey] Damn.
Damn, bro.
- Yeah, bro.
- [Aubrey] I'm not that way anymore, bro.
- I believe you.
That's why I just did you a favor.
- [Aubrey] I'm not, bro.
- I believe you with my entire heart,
which is why I just did you a favor.
- [Aubrey] I'm really not, bro.
- I believe you with my entire heart.
That's why I just did you a favor.
- [Aubrey] Thank you, man.
- You're welcome, bro.
You got this, bro.
Now you can't hide.
A million people are gonna watch this.
Now there's nowhere to hide.
Now just go be a good dude.
Dude, I know you regret being a bad dude.
You were a kid.
It happens all the time.
- I do, bro.
That's the worst.
- I know, bro.
Why do you think I'm keeping
you on for 30 minutes?
People have been wanting me
to hang up with you
for fucking 25 minutes.
Bro, listen to me.
You were a fucking kid.
We all make mistakes.
You just have to say you're sorry,
and that you're ashamed,
and you never are gonna do it again.
- [Aubrey] So you think I can just
like go live then, on my Facebook?
- I do, and I think you
should tag everybody,
and I think you should tell real stories
about how you fucking punked that kid,
and stole that kid's money,
and yelled at that girl.
- [Aubrey] But I have a bigger amount.
Like my Instagram is
more where they watch me.
- Good, so do it there.
Bro, do it everywhere.
Dude, you're scared.
Fucking expose yourself.
Get naked, bro.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, that's
the main thing, bro.
I just want all those people just
to not look at me in that light anymore.
- Exactly, which is why--
- [Aubrey] And if they don't
look at me in that light, bro,
I can walk outside.
- Bro.
- And just--
- Bro, bro.
- [Aubrey] Smell the air.
- Bro, you have to not look at yourself
in that light first by putting it out.
- [Aubrey] 'Cause I don't
personally, but they do,
and--
- Aubrey.
Aubrey.
Because you haven't
fucking said you're sorry.
You're fucking hiding like a little bitch.
- [Aubrey] I haven't.
Yeah, bro.
- I know, bro.
- [Aubrey] And it all started--
- They're right.
You're wrong.
- Stupid shit.
- You're wrong, they're right.
You haven't owned up--
- [Aubrey] But I'm not
like that way anymore, bro.
- But you haven't owned
up to that shit, bro.
- [Aubrey] I haven't.
- I know.
And good news, fucking Twitter,
everyone's posting right now,
Aubrey Medina was a piece
of shit from 2014 to 2017.
You've got no where to hide anymore.
You're good.
You're free.
Now go fucking put on Instagram.
Go make a fucking video
right now, one minute.
Tag everybody, and it's over.
Your poison won't own you no more.
- [Aubrey] I don't want that, bro.
I don't want that.
- So post.
- [Aubrey] Fuck.
You will live this--
- [Aubrey] So you think I
should just like record a video
and just like tell people
like just straight up?
- Yes.
- [Aubrey] I'm sorry because
I thought about making a--
- Yes.
- A video like that.
- Yes, you have to do it now.
Everybody who's watching,
do me a favor on Twitter.
The Aubrey--
- [Aubrey] I don't really have
a big following on Twitter.
- I don't give a fuck,
about your following.
(cross talking)
- Bro, that's really--
- Bro, listen to me.
Listen to me, and listen to me good.
Make the fucking video right now,
because if you don't
you'll be stuck forever.
What are you scared of?
Telling the world you lost?
You just did.
More people heard this than
your fucking Instagram.
It already happened.
What are you, baby Medina?
What's you Twitter?
- [Aubrey] Aubrey the OG.
- I'm sorry, on Instagram.
- The or da?
- [Aubrey] The.
(cross talking)
- The like, T-H-E?
- [Aubrey] Yeah,
T-H-E-A-U-B-R-E-Y-T-H-E O-G.
- T-H-E yeah, right.
You have some sort of dollar sign
SCG fucking thing, or something?
- [Aubrey] My logo, yes.
- Okay.
You had it right the first time.
I got it.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, man I
honestly just changed, man.
I'm not like that.
And nowadays--
- Aubrey, I believe you.
Nobody else does because you
haven't fucking owned it.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Aubrey] Yeah, I see what you saying.
- You're talking about plant food now?
- [Aubrey] Yeah, I was
actually a vegetarian
for seven years and my
mom put me on to that,
and I just recently got back on that,
so I'm trying to spread
health stuff to people.
I've been juicing and trying
to tell people about that.
- Aubrey, I like your face.
I'm serious by the way.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Aubrey, listen to me.
You've got this, bro.
Just make the fucking video.
Bro, can I tell you a secret
that's gonna fucking blow your face off?
- [Aubrey] Bro, I'm ready, bro.
I'm ready for whatever, dude.
Whatever.
- You ready for this?
People don't give a fuck
as much as you think.
They got their own problems.
You know?
- [Aubrey] Yeah, and I realize that, bro,
because when I had that car
I bought that car brand new,
and it wasn't cheap.
You know what I mean?
It was brand new.
I literally just, I got that car
just because I could
do it and I just did it
just because I've always
sold cars like I told you.
Like I was flipping cars,
and stuff like that.
And I was just used to
a certain lifestyle,
so I felt like let me
just buy this car here.
And people are doubting me.
They think I can't do it
anyway, so let me do it.
And then I did it, and
I was just like a couple
of years later like bro why
did I even fucking do this?
I was flipping cars,
because I didn't even want
to have to have a car payment.
- Bro, listen to me.
It's time.
Make the video.
It's time, bro.
You can't fucking post
being grateful is contagious
and all this nice shit on your
fucking Gram and live a lie.
- [Aubrey] That's how I feel though, bro.
That's how I feel.
- You know what else you feel?
You know what you really feel
way more than fucking gratitude?
You feel upset about what you did.
- [Aubrey] I do.
- I know you do, bro.
You think I'm fucking wasting
my 35 minutes here with you?
You're a good kid.
You just had a bad era.
Go fucking tell the world that--
- [Aubrey] And bad fucking friends, bro,
even when I was doing good.
- You picked those friends, dick face.
It's time for you to
fucking take accountability.
- [Aubrey] I am.
- You had bad friends,
'cause you were bad.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, man
I'm gonna do this shit.
- I didn't have bad friends,
us being so the same.
- [Aubrey] So you think I should
just like make a one minute long video
and post it to my Instagram?
- Yes.
Yes, I do.
Right the fuck now.
- [Aubrey] And just title it like--
- I'm Sorry.
- [Aubrey] I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry.
And then fucking get off
whatever you can in the video,
and then write more and whatever
you couldn't finish off,
and fucking tag Karen, and Jamal,
and Rick, and fucking Uncle Charlie,
and fucking tag 'em all,
and fucking say it, and
live your fucking life, bro.
Everybody sucks.
Everybody makes mistakes.
You're a good kid.
You had a bad era, fix it.
- [Aubrey] Very bad, yeah.
- Great, very bad.
Good news, people do way worse.
People murder.
You're fine.
You were a dick face.
Good.
Let's get over it.
Let's move.
- [Aubrey] Yeah, bro I
need to get on that shit.
- But you're not willing
to be a man right now.
You're scared.
- [Aubrey] So you think if
I just post a video, like--
- It'll change, I believe
it will change your life.
Yes, I do.
And more importantly--
- From posting one video?
- Yes, because you have
to change your opinion.
I've gotta get you off of
worrying about those 10 people.
You have to start with you.
It will change you for you,
and then whatever happens
with those 10 will happen based
on where they're at in life.
Two are in a good place.
They'll give you love.
- [Aubrey] Bro, all these people
are telling me to make this video.
(phone beeps)
- Okay.
- [Aubrey] All right.
- Good.
See ya.
(line trilling)
(crew chattering)